був перед міністерством освіти
минулий рік
були передбачені кошти на друк
підручників були передбачені для п'ятих
класів в повному обсязі але через війну
відбувся секвестр ви знаєте забрали
повністю кошти на друк підручників для
п'ятих класів були надруковані тільки
підручники для дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами
і коли ми в травні місяці почали
прогнозувати що ж ми надрукуємо цього
року що ми зможемо надрукувати з
підручників цього року Ми зрозуміли і це
було цілком очевидно оскільки сума
загальна державному бюджеті яка була
передбачена на друк підручників це
тільки всього-на-всього 750 млн грн
потреба значно більше
зрозуміли що ми не надрукуємо все
все те що потрібно в школах і було
вибрано відповідно зроблено змушені були
зробити відповідні пріоритети при друці
підручників ви бачите що буде
надруковано
за кошти державного бюджету вже зараз і
воно уже друкується і фактично вже
більше частина поїхала до обласних
складів це українська мова література
зарубіжна література іноземна мова
історія України
математика природознавство технології
підручники для національних меншин знову
ж таки підручники для дітей з особливими
освітніми потребами це все для шостого
класу надруковано за кошти державного
бюджету зараз надруковано і Зараз уже
їде в школи
завдяки донорам завдяки спонсорам
міжнародним в тому числі надруковані
також окремі підручники для п'ятих
класів Це є українська мова польська
мова математика природничий цикл - це те
що ви бачите на екрані те що було
надруковано за кошти міжнародної
міжнародної донорів окремо історію
України для п'ятого класу ми будемо
друкувати за кошти
державного бюджету цього року тому що
жоден донор не погодився надрукувати
історію України
крім того цього року за кошти державного
бюджету ми надрукували і надрукуємо ще
підручники для національних меншин і
дітей з особливими освітніми потребами
для десятих класів що то що буде з
іншими предметами цілком логічне питання
зараз уже йдуть перемовини зрадо Європи
і вони погодилися і вже найближчим часом
будуть підписані
відповідні Договори меморандуми про друк
підручників для п'ятого класу з
географії для друк підручників з
інформаційних технологій для друк
підручників з мистецтва знову ж таки це
для п'ятих і для шостих класів те що не
можна було надрукувати надрукувати за
кошти державного бюджету
Якщо говорити про скільки з того що
зумовлено з за кошти державного бюджету
що почався друк
ви бачите на екрані це фактично дані на
вчорашній день з того що доставлено уже
до обласних складів
на даний момент ці підручники повинні
розвозитися уже по школах І ми також
зібрали цю інформацію і хочу сказати що
окремі області уже доставлені доставили
повністю до своєї шкіл ті підручники які
є в них на обласний складах деякі ще
тільки планують тому тут важливо також і
обласним державним адміністраціям
активно включитися в процес доставки
підручників щоб вони були в школах на 1
вересня
відсотки тішать вони є високими і ми
сподіваємося що все що було надруковано
опиниться в школах на 1 вересня
це Якщо говорити про реформу нової
української школи як ми її
перезавантажуємо на рівні базової освіти
Якщо ж говорити про
старшу профільну школу
Ми уже починаємо роботу над реформою
старшої профільної школи Ви також чули
про це сьогодні у виступах Михайло
Федорова в Оксана лісового і при
розробленні концепції старшої профільної
школи яку ми готовий будемо презентувати
Я думаю що уже
в жовтні місяці
Ми також презентуємо і стандарт старшої
профільної школи тут є пан Роман він
також детально нам може розказати мене
не чує бо він не одягнув а не чує
також детально розказати про старшого
профільну школу
розуміємо що Пілот старшої профільної
школи є ще складнішим ніж Пілот базової
школи тому і це зараз в активному
обговоренні щоб Пілот старшої профільної
школи Ми почнемо не 26-му році за рік до
початку повноцінного функціонування
старшої профільної школи а уже в 25-му
році щоб в нас було повноцінних два роки
від пілотувати нову модель роботи
старшої профільної школи нові навчальні
програми вільний вибір освітньої
траєкторії учня який ми закладаємо в
стандарт старший профільної школи і які
успішно зможемо реалізувати і
протестувати саме в пілоті тому як ви
бачите викликів стоїть надзвичайно
багато а часу надзвичайно мало Я думаю
що цей рік це буде такий тестовий рік
того як ми зможемо відновити цю реформу
нової української школи а вже з
наступного року повноці нної спланувати
і продовжувати так як вона мала би
працювати як вона була задумана дякую
не чути зараз чути Дякую
якщо можна кілька запитань в режимі Бліц
стосовно того що ви казали з приводу
підручників
5-6-10 Ми почули А що буде з першим
класом адже їхні підручники
використовувалися вже 5 років і
відповідно ну мають бути передруковані
чи є інформація з цього приводу Так
дякую за запитання пані Івана насправді
актуальне питання і
як я говорив
Міністерство змушене було приватизувати
те що воно буде друкувати маючи ті
бюджети які були які є в міністерстві
надрукувати все що нам потрібно
неможливо Якщо говорити про пріоритети
п'ятий і шостий клас це класи нової
української школи це нові навчальні
програми по яких немає жодних
підручників перший клас другий клас в
них є надруковані підручники так 5 років
але актуальність їхнє все ж таки не
втрачена порівняно з тим Які
взагалі від сутністю будь-яких
підручників тому звичайно спочатку ми
друкуємо для
класів яких взагалі немає підручників а
тоді будемо повертатися до перших других
в нас вже і дев'ятій і 10-й класи Також
потрібно оновлювати ці підручники
Зрозуміло А та ідея яка була щоб для
початкової школи не друкувалися тверді
підручники на 5 років а робилися
комплекти як робочі зошити які дешевші в
друкові і можливо більш зручні
використання особливо в початковій школі
ще і вона досі актуальна так конкурси
підручників які відбулися є відповідні
накази Міністерства освіти про
затвердження переліку друку підручників
та посібників і саме в них є закладено
Що для першого класу за наявності
повністю фінансового ресурсу мали бути
би надруковані саме посібники а не
підручники ті які були класичні і які
мали би друкуватися щороку для учнів
знову ж таки повторюся війна і фінанс-
фінансові можливості не дали можливості
це зробити І ще одне це було таке
тактичне питання яке болить нам кожного
року друг підручників але ще одне є
стратегічне питання щодо старшої
профільної школи про Пілот якої ви
згадали що його потрібно починати раніше
А що буде з сьомим класом який зараз
пілотує нуш тому що вони пілотують
програму дванадцятирічної школи але
закінчувати от вони в школу тоді коли ще
українська середня школа залишатиметься
11-річною чи є вже бачення скільки років
вчитимуться Ці діти і як це буде
реалізовано
бачення є але воно насправді дуже
дискусійне тому що зараз ми пілотуємо
нову українську школу в гімназіях або в
ліцеях які є класичними школами які
функціонували вже давно які будуть
функціонувати Якщо ж ми говоримо про
пілотування старшої профільної школи то
ми розуміємо що це пілотування буде
відбуватися в академічних ліцеях це
зовсім інший тип закладу який мають бути
створені і тут Навіть якби ми не
зміщували Пілот на рік швидше всерівно
не обов'язково Ці пілотні школи які
зараз є стали би пілотними школами
старшої профільної школи адже
академічний ліцей - це я ще раз
повторюється концепцію кого ми
найближчим часом презентуємо це зовсім
інший тип закладу і
щодо тих учнів які зараз навчаються в
пілоті оскільки Пілот почнеться на рік
швидше в пілотних закладах вони зможуть
продовжувати навчання саме в тих
пілотних
академічних ліцеїв які будуть
функціонувати можливо можливо співпадуть
наша вибірка пілотних академічних ліцеїв
з мережею тих пілотних шкіл які є зараз
але можуть бути і чимало інших правильно
Я вас розумію не можуть бути
Дякую дуже Андрій Сташків заступник
міністра освіти і науки зараз хотіла б
надати слово лілії Гриневич Міністр
освіти і науки в 16-19 роках і перший
проректорці університет Київського
університету Грінченка
Дуже дякую
Я хочу зараз запропонувати таке
більш широке бачення тому що заступник
Міністра зупинився саме на гарячих
питаннях ми всі хочемо знати на них
відповідь А я спробую розгорнути бачення
перезавантаження нової української школи
в тих умовах які ми маємо зараз але на
ширшу перспективу ну перш за все от
заступник Міністра не говорив а він живе
в цьому і Міністерство живе в цьому
всьому живе вся країна тому що система
освіти має свої наслідки і зокрема
реформа має свої наслідки від війни тому
що починаючи від наших зруйнованих
класів які ми обладнали для початкової
школи нуш в багатьох областях до
зруйнованих шкіл Як ви бачите зараз
більш ніж кожна десята школа нашої
країни вона зруйнована і
це потребує бачення того як ми будемо
відновлювати цю інфраструктуру і
наповнювати її новим змістом сьогодні от
останній дослідження свідчать про те що
75%
учнів українських які зараз знаходяться
в Україні мають ознаки когнітив-
когнітивні ознаки стресу це теж дані які
повинні бути враховані в освітньому
процесі міграційні процеси які зрозуміли
завершиться тим що нам треба зрозуміти
не тільки як привабити що запропонувати
дітям які будуть повертатися з-за
кордону але як їх найкраще адаптувати в
українській системі освіти Ми зіткнемось
з освітніми втратами і розривами при
цьому заморожений рівень оплати праці до
цього часу і це чудово що сьогодні
прозвучало про перегляд системи оплати
праці підвищення заробітної плати
результати праці але погляньте що в нас
відбувається в нас ще до цього часу
третина шкіл має працювати дистанційно А
є частина дітей які будуть на змішаному
навчанні і це означає що те що ми
вважали тимчасовим воно стає дуже
постійним і це означає що якість
онлайн освіти має бути неймовірно інакше
ніж вона є сьогодні в пересічній школі
окрім того до цього часу нус нуш жила
без цільової субвенції і радо вітаємо те
що субвенція повертається але до чого це
приводить до чого це приводить я скажу
перед тим щоб трошечки поліпшити настрій
бо
ця ситуація з війною нам ще також дала
приводи на для натхнення Ну от те що
показують наші вчителі і наші діти воно
абсолютно дивує і ця мужність і цей
запал ну про ви знаєте ці сюжети те що
все ми вміємо вже робити в укриттях
проте як вчителі Біля зруйнованих своїх
будинків давали уроки дистанційні але
мене особисто надзвичайно надихається
картинка у ці хлопчики в Харківській
області на деокупованій території це
випускники нової української школи Вони
якраз цей час були в четвертому класі і
там не було зв'язку і От коли відбулося
деокупація Ці діти вже вийшли з підвалів
вони знайшли отакий горб де був
інтернет-зв'язок ізбудували власноруч
оцю халабуду для того щоб з'єднатися з
своєю вчителькою онлайн І нарешті бути
на уроці от щоб ми розуміли що означає
як ця рутина для українських дітей
а сьогодні таких дітей є багато і я
послуговуюся тут схемою Сергія Горбачова
і це означає що семи різними категоріями
дітей дітей які
внутрішньо переміщені дітей які
були яких менше торкнулися війна яких
більше торкнулася війна в сенсі
пропусків освітнього процесу ті які за
кордоном всі ці різні групи будуть мати
свої навчальні втрати які є
індивідуальними і стосуються ну досвіду
особистого конкретної дитини і їх треба
міряти індивідуально і навчальні розриви
Це між групами розриви в нас нас чекає
шановні дорогі мої освітяни більше
поділів наших класах ніж було До того
часу навіть сидіти коли повернуться з
різних систем освіти це те що окремі
групи з якими треба буде цільово
працювати І
це окрема тема але ми маємо розумі це
щодо реформи освіти в нас включаються
нові напрямки які треба передбачати і
тому ця освітня політика яку зараз
здійснює чинний Міністерство освіти і
надалі мусить водночас іти і на
подолання освітніх втрат і на
забезпечення оцієї майбутньої успішної
самореалізації українців і звичайно на
розвиток тої країни яку ми чекаємо
особливість Яка ще є внаслідок війни От
дивіться це недавні опитування молодих
людей про те що лише
25% українських підлітків відчувають
опору в собі а 83% хочуть дізнатись як
можуть підтримувати себе у важкі часи і
коли їх питаєш який би ти хотів мати
додатковий предмет вони кажуть
психологія
Уявіть собі Ну в нашому поколінні коли
ми себе Вже Так ідентифікували ми хотіли
психології університет під років 30 так
а вони вже цього хочуть вони цього
потребують і це треба врахувати в змісті
освіти їм потрібно життєва стійкість
здатність до адаптації до розуміння і
управління емоції і тому коли ми в
загальному стратегічного говоримо про
додану цінність реформи нова українська
школа то вона полягає звісно в
компетентнісному підході який ми
намагаємося впроваджувати так всі ці
роки що це не тільки знання вміння їх
застосовувати на практиці а також
цінності на основі яких ми виробляємо
ставлення дітей до різних ситуацій
потоків інформації але також це крім
оновлених академічних знань
соціально-емоційні м'які навички які їм
потрібні не менше ніж академічні знання
для
життєвого успіху
що сповільнило реформу нуш Вибачте я
прошу це сприйняти
ну сприйняти так як є я нікого не хочу
образити але ми повинні собі говорити
правду по-перше Я вважаю що при
впровадженні нуш у 5 класі
загальнодержавно В нас відбулося
імітація впровадження державного
стандарту базової освіти Я впевнена що у
нас є сотні шкіл і тисячі вчителів які
все-таки змогли От вчителі-предметники і
директори шкіл впровадити справді
державний стандарт базової освіти
запропонувати методики компетентнісного
навчання і оце дбати і про використання
знань на для вирішення практичних
завдань і дбати про формування ставлень
і брати до уваги всі оці навчальні
результати виписані в державному
стандарті але Шановні колеги навіть як
ми беремо частину підручників які
затверджені і мають гриф Міністерство
освіти і науки То вони не відповідають
навчальним результатам державного
стандарту
що це таке Це зміни на обкладинка це
імітація імітація є страшніша ніж
нероблення тому що Ми розказуємо Що ми
робимо реформу а насправді в кінцевому
рахунку ми не будемо мати результату і я
думаю що
найправильніше що можна зробити це
подивитися цей справді в очі і
переглянути і зокрема використовуючи
досвід отут присутніх пілотних шкіл тому
що вони значно більше знають про помилки
проблеми і можливі рішення ніж інші
школи які ідуть вже рік лише за ними і
тому я вважаю що нам потрібна оця
ревізія зворотний зв'язок і по
підручниках які вже були використані
звісно недостатньо комунікація Тому що
вчитель який хоче щось впровадити він
повинен мати внутрішню підтримку у школі
цим повинні керуватися
кольори закладів освіти
відсутність і цецентралізовано
підвищення кваліфікації вчителів велика
проблема я вам хочу сказати в освіторії
зроблений прекрасний Я вважаю курс він
трохи пізно був зроблений але він був
зроблений силами громадськості так е-е
який варто подивитись кожному
вчителю-предметнику і директору школи
але якщо ви подивитеся охоплення цього
курсу то це зовсім не національне
охоплення і це означає що ми вже його
Маємо зробити обов'язковим для
використання
Ну і скасування цільових освітніх
субвенцій це вже неодноразово сьогодні
звучала і я просто можу апелювати до
влади бо не все залежить від
Міністерства освіти і науки ця постанова
має пройти горнила всіх міністерств і
сьогодні розпочали слова цитатою
черчилля так про те що якщо не давати
гроші освіти то заради чого ми воюємо Та
це дуже якраз релевантно до затвердження
постанови і
представлення уряду цієї цього аргументу
Я хочу ще розумію що ми обмежені в часі
Лише так фрагментарно поділитися думками
з приводу того що нам зараз потрібно теж
подивитися і на оновлення стандартів
змісту і програм через призму призму
війни і післявоєнного періоду
ну дехто скаже слухайте ми тут щойно
впроваджуємо стандарт ще його не не
впровадили А ви вже хочете щось
оновлювати Справа в тому що по-перше ми
вже бачимо ми робимо ми йдемо по зовсім
новому шляху і життя дуже швидке і треба
все-таки реагувати наприклад питання
лице оці напрямки яких я зараз торкнусь
їх всього-на-всього 5 це менше ніж є в
напрямках реалізації нової української
школи але питання наприклад
україноцентричності і глобального
контексту в змісті освіти Ми маємо
розглянути тому що україноцентричні
питання історії географії літератури
мистецтва мови ви розумієте з цією
війною у нас просто як це оптика
змінюється і найстрашніше що цей
жахливий урок ще один урок геноциду
проти українського народу Ми повинні
запам'ятати і зафіксувати в наших
програмах це питання формування
української ідентичності і це питання
того щоб історичний маятник Ніколин
знову не відгорнувся в інший бік тому що
в нас вже були приклади Вибачте
Помаранчева революція так такий такий
національний підйом А після того
приходить Янукович і гасла коли значить
все всі одно я дуже прошу звернути на це
увагу посилення з теми світи інноваційна
компетентність - Це наша сила у
порівнянні навіть стандартами інших
країн велике питання в тому що на нашу
думкою Чим більше ми спілкуємося з
вчителями оцей компонент природничі
науки зокрема в стандарті базової освіти
і ми про це вже говорили з Романом
богдановичем з колегами розробниками
стандарту можливо варто переглянути Поки
воно дійде до 8-9 класу на тій стадії
7-9-й клас І що далі буде в 10-12 тому
що там є питання відповідності цих тем і
огортання всього циклу до дев'ятого
класу до віку 16 років
захист вітчизни громадянська
компетентність у провадження
соціально-емоційного навчання І звісно
окремий навчальний план для учнів які
знаходяться за кордоном чим більше вони
знаходяться за кордоном тим важче їм
буде інтегруватися назад в українську
систему освіти Тому зараз Міністерство
вже зробило багато кроків з цього
приводу Але можливо нам можна піти ще
далі наскрізна спеціалізація що і тут
буду говорити тут окрема секція працює
на цю тему але мушу сказати що всіх вас
заохочують піти на вшо бо там є
діагностичні тести по те це те що в
реформі нуш І взагалі в реформуванні
Освіти нам дає підґрунтя для того щоб ми
могли визначити освітній втрати і
працювати далі з дітьми і пробувати
персоналізувати їхнє навчання
є зараз дуже багато ресурсів не маю часу
на цьому
зупинятися хотіла б надзвичайно
заохотити з отого всього що написано на
слайді
дотворення спільнот
вчителів-предметників навколо ідей нуш
чим було сильна початкова школа коли ми
перезавантажували в нас були оці учні
тренінги на базі інститутів
післядипломної освіти і колеги інститути
післядипломної освіти ви поряд з
системою підвищення кваліфікації яка за
вибором вчителя ви є для нас основою
власне для такої цільової очної
підтримки реформи тому що тоді
пам'ятаєте ці спільноти тренерів вони
навколо себе творили спільноти вчителів
в нас нема зараз спільнот математики
білогів мовників які перейняті
філософією нуш і методиками нуш я думаю
що якщо ми цього досягнемо цього року ми
тоді з реально зможемо перевантажити
реформу не забувайте про новий
професійний стандарт вчителя тому що
творячи цей професійний стандарт ми
намагалися
віддзеркалити філософію нової
української школи і ще от до безпеки
інклюзивності освітнього середовища все
що ви бачите на слайді хочу сказати
тільки одне ми зараз маємо можливість
відбудовувати
наші освітні простори Там де вони
зруйновані або за нашу субвенцію яка
прийде з державного бюджету будь ласка
наповнюйте це не тільки стінами а новою
філософією навчання от в чому наша
велика відповідальність
дякую Я мабуть завершу Пробачте Що так
Що так довго дивіться останній слайд вам
от просто сфотографуйте і всюди
розказуйте
70% дітей хочуть навчатись жити в
Україні а 86 бачать своє майбутнє в
Україні до війни таких цифр не було
заради цих дітей варта працювати
старатися жити і розвивати нуш
Дякую Лілія Михайлівно
якраз прозвучало ваші в вашому виступі
важливо питання які одразу хочеться
переадресувати роману шияну як людині
яка вже багато років є е-е головним
місцем точкою зборки стандартів і
реформування змісту освіти Власне кажучи
те що ви сказали про підручники для 5-6
класів а справді перші два роки
реформи нуш в базовій середній школі
показали що можливо щось і треба
переглянути особливо якщо стосується
змісту освіти особливо враховуючи
ті обставини в яких 5,6 класи заходили в
реформу
Роман Шиян заступник директорки команди
підтримки реформ
чекаємо від вас
апдеїту по актуальній ситуації що
відбувається зі стандартами Чи є зараз
пере гляд стандарту базової середньої
освіти які ви бачите речі які можливо
можна змінити там дублювання які можна
усунути відсутність цінностей нуш як
можна від них позбавитись які думки на
цю тему
і тому треба дуже стисло висловлюватися
але я все-таки почну з такої невеличкої
рефлексіїї коли ти перебуваєш от в цьому
телевізорі ну казочка колись була Джек в
телевізорі і ти розумієш що зараз
система перезавантажать то ти себе
почуваєш Трохи так двозначно тому що ти
не знаєш чого операційна система
відновиться І взагалі як це далі чи
налаштування не зміняться і чи не
пропадуть оці всі файли з усіма цими
стандартами які там були по складені
і я дуже добре пам'ятаю Тут момент коли
ти пан Андрій з'явився в міністерстві
Ірини Михайлівна переступила поріг
міністерства в якісь дні квітня чи
травня цього року і е-е п Андрій почав з
того що Ну приблизно з тих тест який
сьогодні були на початку про те що все
зависло і нічого не відбувалося І я
пам'ятаю спонтанно відповів що я не хочу
бути адвокатом диявола але людей які але
такі деякі речі на початку коли ми
входили були зроблені і Була оця
ініціація пов'язана з
залученням партнерів і колег з
інститутів післядипломної педагогічної
освіти коли ми оці всі команди
створювали і в інститутах і пілотних
школах одночасно тобто ці інститутські
команди і команди шкіл пілотних
проживали однакові досвід і далі
інститути підхоплювали цю всю історію
яка була пов'язана з тим аби
стандарт базової освіти а він є досить
інструментальним документом
привласнювати у вигляді освітньої
програми закладу так типова освітня
програма закладу І це одне з точкових
рішення Яке ще має ще ми маємо зробити
зараз і я думаю це відповідь пряма на
ваше запитання Що перегляд стандарту
базової
освіти потрібен після того як ми
завершимо зі стандартом профільної
середньої освіти Можливо навіть однією
постановою
але тому що там будуть певні нести ковки
там ще є особлива роль цього 10-го класу
це все ще потребує потребує
узгодження і я скажу що
зараз ми там вже бачимо певні певні речі
які треба у відповідники і навіть більше
ми маємо тоді після того повернутися до
стандарту початкової освіти
а спроба його реалізувати була вже в
цьому році ще до того як Прийшла нова
команда і
фактично у відповіднити його за навіть
за формою тому що тих того рівня
очікуваних результатів навчання які є в
стандарті базові і будуть в стандарті
профільної середньої освіти в стандарті
порядкової немає ці
найдокладніші вимо ги до результатів
навчання живуть в типових освітніх
програмах і
від цього я мабуть все-таки перейду до
цієї презентації і дуже швидко її
пробіжу Якщо мені це вдасться Куди я маю
керувати цей
дивіться для того щоб давати
усвідомлення відповіді на питання Навіщо
це перезавантаження і таке інше потрібні
дані а цих даних і ці дані в різний
спосіб впродовж цього всього часу
збиралися як в початковій школі так і
далі от ви бачите внизу панель з
партнерами Це добре і погано тому що з
одного боку ніби різні зусилля з різних
боків а з іншого боку воно таке
фрагментоване що звести це докупи можуть
хіба такі фахівці як от Василь Терещенко
якому Я вдячний за оцю за оцю
презентацію І власне ми проводили
систематичні опитування зворотний
зв'язок Він звичайно був не
репрезентативний бо за задумом Пілот
пілотні мережа пілотних шкіл не при
репрезентативне тому порівнювати
порівнювати складно
такі речі які справді допоможуть в
майбутньому робити усвідомленні висновки
це
те щоб здійснюється українським центром
оцінювання якості і ми вперше бачитимемо
результат нової української школи аж
після того дослідження яке буде
проведене Наступної весни А це тобто
після того ще пройде час і я сьогодні
тут в цій презентації цього немає але
сьогодні дізнався що
смарт освіта має намір провести
опитування в
5-6 класах масової практики і це теж дам
нам дасть певні певні дані і Ну ми дуже
дорожимо також тим дослідженням якими
свого часу зробили на початку третього
класу Коли ми глибинно зайшли і
спостерігали за діяльністю учнів це був
такий
дослідження в якому брали участь наші
колеги з Варшавського університету
Тобто було Це був такий приклад
ретельного ретельного
[музика]
спроби Там ми побачили єдине ми побачили
що учні пілотних закладів трохи
відкритіші ця річ пов'язана з
наскрізними вміннями Ну вона там працює
і відверто скажу що в когнітивній сфері
і нас до речі про це колись попереджали
наші колеги колеги з Lego foundation що
ми можемо побачити цей провал Якщо ця
нова реформа зайде Ми повинні бути до
цього готовими от
очевидно що через ковід і війну ми ми не
вимірюємо і не можемо зараз досліджувати
вплив нової української школи та її
ефективність але дані з якими можна
згодом порівнюватися і тут я залишаю
простір для для цієї перспективи
Тетяні вони вони потрібні от
е-е Ми дуже сподіваємося І тут на іншій
панелі буде презентовано
результати дослідження яке проводилося в
контексті оцінювання освітніх втрат і
для нуш це фактично
той зріз на рівні результатів навчання
за результатами першого циклу базової
освіти це теж дуже важливо мати ці дані
От і
тому як висновок от з цього свого цієї
частини Я хотів би сказати таке що
Пілот даних з пілоту ніколи не буде Вони
ніколи не зможуть служити підставою для
того щоб приймати системні рішення щодо
змін в реформі по її в процесі її
впровадження ми мусимо звернути увагу на
те що відбувається в масовій практиці
щоб не опинитися в ситуації подібне до
тієї яку Ми зараз в початковій освіті
коли цикл вже фактично пройшов 5 років
минуло новий Нове покоління підручників
Ну якось
заходить але ми не маємо цих уроків оце
от основний висновок це от
шукати ці інструменти системно їх
впроваджувати для того щоб мати
відповіді на ті
Тобто щоб
вивчати ці ті уроки Ну так звані lessons
lerness з того що відбувається саме не
лише в пілоті але також і в масовій
практиці
40 підручників з української мови за
програмою нуш напевно Може поділитися
своїм вже практичним досвідом
про ті уроки які ми бачимо відносно
навчальних матеріалів які потрапляють до
шкіл які потрапляють до вчителів і які
називаються нуш Але чи завжди вони є нуш
і що нам власне робити для того щоб
уникнути мікрування і як сказала Лілія
Михайлівна
коли бачимо в лінійці тих підручників
які все ж таки потрапляють в українські
класи нуш але насправді вони не
відповідають Ні тому що написано в
стандарті ні цінностям нуш які
закладалися в реформу прошу
Зараз я спробую
так
мені не працює
коли з'явиться на екрані тоді можна буде
клікати Я прошу технічну команду швидше
завантажити презентацію але ви можете
поки починати в будь-якому разі Я
сьогодні
представляю погляд на реформу зсередини
або хочете знизу тому що буду говорити
про погляд авторів які готують
імплементацію тобто готують матеріали
готують підручники проходять цей шлях і
про погляд з точки зору з боку вчителів
які це впроваджують тому що я сама мала
досвід впровадження реформи Працюючи в
школі І ми також дуже багато спілкуємося
з колегами які впроваджують реформу з
усієї України в нас є група такої
спільнотивої підтримки дає 4000 вчителів
з усієї України і вони ради діляться
своїми
вдалими і невдалими випадками які були і
які призвели або вдалого або до
невдалого результату впровадження
така простенька метафора для початку
оскільки я говорю як авторка як
вчителька то я маю дати якийсь
навчальний контент от власне кажучи з
нього і почнемо уявімо що вам треба
післязавтра проїхати
140 кілометрів знайомою дорогою і
досягти якогось пункту в який транспорт
ви оберете із двох які є перед вами
транспорт а
хтось пізнає дуже добре знайому модель
українського виробника так чи транспорт
б подумайте для себе я ризикнув
припустити що для 140 кілометрів через
день
більшість зупиняться все-таки На
варіанті А я правильно ризикнула
припустити
очевидно що за цими механізмами крилися
два зрозумілі види транспорту і в таких
самих умовах приблизно опиняємося і ми
як автори і вчителі перед якими є добре
знайомий вивчений традиційний шлях де є
матеріали де є досвід із сотні уроків
які вони вже мали в межах впровадження
навчання зі свого предмету і це такий
собі умовний транспорт А і Є вчителі
звичайно прекрасні вчителі які ризикують
шукають шляхи як же ж опанувати цю
складну систему самостійно і обирають
все-таки варіант б зрозуміло що якщо ми
говоримо про 140 км можете їх перекласти
на 140 годин як приблизно з української
мови в 5-6 класі і про те що треба їхати
післязавтра очевидно що варіант б
оберуть тільки несміливіші найризиковіші
найпрогресивніші і я дуже хочу
відзначити цей момент тому що справді
вчителі які займаються справжнім про
вадженням Ну що вони такі такі і є
що допоможе на нашу думку як авторів як
вчителів зробити транспорт б більш
доступним для наших вчителів перш за все
це стратегічне планування і я хочу
звернути увагу на три дуже важливі
пункти які насправді не потребують
якихось великих грошових вливань або
командних надзвичайно Великих зусиль
перші і дуже важливий момент це
стратегічне планування нам дуже потрібен
час просто час для написання модельних
програм для написання підручників для
апробації і для виправлення реальних
чесно виявлених помилок при якій йшлося
сьогодні вже це надзвичайно важливо
зараз я покажу один слайд з тим яка є
реальність в сенсі часу і ми побачимо в
яких умовах відбувається це наша подорож
після завтра
другий важливий стратегічний пункт це
звичайно системне навчання вчителів але
не фрагментарне а цілісне цілісне
стратегічне яке має свій шлях від
найпростішого до найскладнішого
впровадження тому що реформа - це не
просто Держстандарт це не просто коли ми
писали наш підручник для п'ятого класу
ми витратили кілька місяців для того щоб
як автори зрозуміти що закладено в цих
результатах навчання що ми маємо
транслювати в підручниках як вони
поєднані які є простішими які є
складнішими які мають закінчитися в
шостому класі які можуть бути
наскрізними це дуже багато важливих
дрібних запитань де в нас не було
допомоги а дуже би хотілося звичайно
піти кудись звернути і спитати Ну як це
працює Покажіть будь ласка Ну і звичайно
на третій пункт Я хочу підкреслити це
дуже важливий момент чесність в оцінках
відповідності матеріалів і навчання яке
ми пропонуємо для вчителів реальним
цінностям нової української школи тому
що на сьогодні крім явища імітацій про
яке йшлося є таке саме явище і в
навчанні вчителів проведені
різноманітних вебінарів семінарів
отримання сертифікатів Я думаю що Всі
розуміють про що йдеться Якщо говорити
про час така реальність є на сьогодні ми
зараз в цьому таймлайні в липні цього
року 23 Ми отримали модельні програми
для 7-9 класів тобто опубліковані
в серпні тобто вже фактично зараз мають
відбутися
пілоти тобто розпочатися ми маємо надати
плотні матеріали для сьомих класів
листопад грудень цього самого року
відбудеться початок процедури конкурсу
підручників для сьомих класів подивимося
чесно на цю стрічку часу якщо ми є
авторами які чекають програм то ми в
липні їх побачимо і за місяць маємо
підготувати пілотні нові абсолютно
матеріали для шкіл наскільки реально це
зробити якісно наскільки це реально
зробити глибоко зробити по-новому чим
можна скористатися тією таврією з
малюнка а яка була на початку звичайно
цей шлях швидший реальніший якщо в мене
така Таврія є видана за попередні роки і
стоїть шафі то очевидно що є Спокуса
скористатися саме нею а не керувати
якісь зовсім новий незрозумілий ні для
кого шлях тому перший дуже важливий
момент переглянути час
звичайно ми не можемо тут говорити про
сьомий клас очевидно тут вже йдеться так
як ідеться але ми можемо говорити про
старшу школу мене дуже тішить ця думка
що фокус вже змістився на 2025 рік і
очевидно зараз час вже говорити про
програми і матеріали для старшої школи
щоб мати Трішки більше часу на написання
вчителям на розуміння на навчання і на
апробацію звичайно в ідеальному в
ідеальному форматі Мені би так бачилося
що ми би мали мати хоча би два роки на
написання підручника та навчання авторів
якого дуже не вистачає тому що в авторів
дуже різне розуміння реформи і її змісту
і ви це Бачите за тими матеріалами які
потрапляють школи абсолютно різне і один
рік хоча би на пробацію та врахування
чесних результатів чесними результатами
має бути мають бути результати
незалежних експертизи і На мою думку це
надзвичайно важливий момент яка повинна
мати в часі також ось це місце для того
щоб врахувати помилки і виправити
на зараз фактично грифування
відбувається в таких термінах що часу на
внесення якісних результатів в
підручнику не залишаються тому що
грифування впритул
наближена до початку конкурсу
підручників тому в таких темпах звичайно
врахувати якісь якісні коментарі розлоги
і неможливо ну крім того що хотілось би
мати такий інститут експертизи можливо
поза межами держави який би був не
заангажований який би міг давати чесний
справедливий зворотний зв'язок
другий момент насправді останній я
вибрала два такі для фокусу сьогодні це
допомога вчителям
саме допомога
першим важливим кроком про який говорять
всі вчителі які починають працювати з
нової української школи
Повинен був би бути такий атомарний
розбір державного стандарту для кожної
галузі тому що вчителі дуже часто не
розуміють і не знають взагалі що це за
документ що його треба подивитися
почитати а ще більше розібрати і
зрозуміти що з їхньої галузі криється в
цьому державному стандарті це великий
документ вчителів дуже багато
бюрократичної роботи без цього якщо вже
є готові рішення То навіщо йти до
першоджерела А це надзвичайно важливо
тому що розуміння цінностей які
закладені в державному стандарті дає
можливість обирати свої траєкторії де є
можливість бачити до чого ми маємо
готувати учнів які результати ми маємо
допомогти їм виховати виростити за цей
цикл яким ми працюємо в новій
українській школі і другий пункт який
міг би змотивувати вчителів дивитися на
Держстандарт аналізувати дивитися на
свою галузь на скрізь на це
звичайно системне навчання з досягнення
таких результатів тобто як аналізувати
матеріали як оцінювати як обирати
навчальні траєкторії якщо вчитель зможе
якісно оцінити матеріали відповідно до
того що є закладено в державному
стандарті то він буде робити якісний
вибір
цей вибір Звичайно це також дуже
важливий момент і такий вибір можна
можна спрогнозувати буде очікувати своєї
свого результату тобто вибір треба
плекати вибір треба підтримувати і вибір
має повинен мати чесні наслідки тобто
Вчитель повинен розуміти що не методист
обирає не бібліотека обирає матеріал а
він зі своєю професійною спільнотою
зупиняється на тій чи цій траєкторії за
якою він хоче це навчання вести і
запроваджувати це надзвичайно важлива
вчительське розуміння відповідальності
за ось цей вибір що вчитель бере той
підручник який він отримає щоб вчитель
обере ту траєкторію яка йому буде
найближчою це надзвичайно важливо на
рівні ментальному на рівні усвідомлення
і впровадження Ну і звичайно такий дуже
важливий пункт про те що чинні
інструменти оцінювання результатів нуш
повинні бути зрозумілими зараз вчителі в
середній школі з якими ми спілкуємося
інколи говорять Я йду за старою
траєкторією за старою програмою за
старим підручником У нас все добре
навіщо нам що змінювати все працює і
вони не розуміють на якому етапі з учням
знадобляться ці знання офіційно тобто чи
буде якесь тестування Чи буде якась
перевірка чи буде щось іще змотиваторів
зовнішніх що їх без спонукало піти і
розібратися і все-таки піти цю машину з
траєкторії б хоча Вона вимагає більше
ресурсів часу з точки зору вчителя це
оптимістичний останній слайд Я дуже
люблю його використовувати Чому він
оптимістичний бо він має дати надію
Надія в тому що концептуально нуш має
прекрасний перспективи і державний
стандарт насправді дає дуже багато
можливостей рамкових для нового навчання
і справжнього те що з ним на певних
етапах Щось пішло не так Це ситуації які
треба аналізувати і робити висновки але
бачите ліва частина в нього все ще дуже
перспективне дякую дякую Анастасія
власне дуже дуже плавний у нас виходить
перехід до теми оцінювання і яка також
має реформуватися з разом запровадженням
нуш і переходом її все в старші і старші
класи і це чудове запитання так власне
коли ж дітям знадобляться результати
нуш
саме для того коли їх будуть оцінювати
за цим це насправді величезне питання
тому що у нас оцінювання певним чином я
Я вам не скажу викривлене інколи воно
багатьом видається саме
найнеобхіднішою частиною навчання і ми
дуже часто чуємо цей від вчителів і від
батьків і це транслюється дітям також
вони часто думають що вони навчаються
для оцінювання але це безумовно не так і
це теж частина реформи і частина тих
змін які ми маємо пройти ну і звісно
розпитаємо ми про це Тетяну Вакуленко
директорку центру оцінювання якості
освіти і власне як у нас у змінюється
оцінювання якщо ми говоримо звісно про
підсумкове вашому випадку з розвитком
реформи нуш але також і про те що
оцінювання як моніторинг має давати для
освітньої політики і для її коригування
власне щойно концепція нової української
школи
залунала або так засяяла в тому
в тому віконечку ми почали думати про те
яким чином зробити оцінювання Яке би
відповідало концепції нової української
школи і ми зібрали велику і хорошу
робочу групу яка розробляла стратегії
освітніх оцінювань в Україні і тоді вона
амбітна називалася до 2030 року
думати
прогностично і перспективно це одна з
характерних рис українського центру
оцінювання якості освіти тому що те що
показувала Анастасія от прекрасно
конячку де заду все ок а спереду Не дуже
то в оцінюванні Так не можна якщо ви
хочете щоби оцінювання не нашкодило
системі
воно має бути намальовано гармонійно і
бажано так Як Ну з хвостика половина
цієї школи цієї конячки Да ми тоді ще
розуміли що оцінювання стандартизоване
це є частина важлива реформи Чому Тому
що для того щоб якісний імплементувати
реформу потрібні дані
і ці дані мають бути чистими
об'єктивними акуратними якби ми
впроваджували цю ідею цю стратегію так
як ми це планували то зараз у нас би не
було питань проте Які в нас є навчальні
втрати навчальні розриви Ми би знали
відповіді на ці питання і знали би їх
чесні ці відповіді
більш Зате для того щоб говорити про
концепцію нової української школи про
ідеї абсолютно і докорінного зміна
системи освіти нам дуже потрібна
інформація яка би була корисна не тільки
політикам і управлінцям а насамперед
вчителям про те що вони роблять
правильно що вони роблять неправильно
хороші Об'єктивні дані оцінювання Це
прямий і чіткий дороговказ для педагогів
про те як їм працювати нам також
потрібні були інструменти які би
дозволили нам забезпечувати насправді
питання рівності в освіті Ми Точно
знаємо що освіта в нас має великий
високий рівень цегрегації це показало
зокрема дослідження Піза і ці всі
питання ми хотіли вирішити принаймні
підійти до Їх рішення
створивши систему стандартизованих
оцінювань на ключових етапах здобуття
освіти
є країни в яких є оцінювання ледь не
після Кожного семестру стандартизовані і
ці країни часто говорять що вони
перетестують учнів учнів втомлюються
учні навчаються лише для оцінювання Учні
не знають яким способом ще їм свої
компетентності продемонструвати як на
тестах часто фальшують можуть
фальшуватися результати Тобто це
проблемна штука є країна така як Україна
які все зводять до зараз принаймні до
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання на
етапі випуску
І коли що ви робили 11 років в школі Ви
дізнаєтеся тільки в травні випускного
класу і коли Перепрошую але вже рятувати
пізно
випускаєте цю дитину і не знаєте нічого
про неї до цього є сотні батьків які
звертаються до української регіональних
центрів оцінювання якості освіти
наприкінці 10-го класу для їхніх дітей
або на початку 11-го і питають зробіть
їм щось тому що ми не знаємо що вони
знають з репетиторами 10 років вчилися
що там вивчили невідомо
в школі ніби прекрасні оцінки що там
невідомо а потім отримують результати
зовнішнього незалежного оцінювання або
зараз національному мультипредметного
тесту і дивується що результати
абсолютно не відповідають тимчі
лікуванням які були тому що
стандартизованих інструментів раніше не
мали це система передбачала би що ми
проводимо оцінювання за інструментом
розробленим стандартизований
централізовано на етапі четвертого класу
ці інструменти мали би впроваджувати
вчителі і вчительки в своїх закладах
освіти Ми би не говорили про те що має
бути система
знаєте тимчасових екзаменаційних центрів
пунктів тестування тобто додаткового
старасу для учнів там насправді було би
мінімум коли би ми говорили про дев'ятий
клас ми поговорили про гібридну модель
де заклади освіти надають приміщення і
можливості для проходження оцінювання
але можуть бути експерти які приїздять
до закладу освіти для того щоб допомогти
закладу освіти
А 11-й 12-й клас перспективі тестування
проводилося б максимально так як
проводиться зараз коли ми говоримо про
випускні Випробування
щоби нам Це дало Ми би могли збирати
акуратні дані Ми би могли їх аналізувати
і ми могли працювати з ними навіть на
рівні закладу освіти
що би нам це не дало нам би це не дало
інструменти впливу на школу В якому
сенсі тому що важливо розуміти що
будь-які результати пов'язані не тільки
з діяльністю педагогічного колективу а й
з передумовами які в закладі освіти ви
не можете очікувати одних і тих самих
результатів від великого столичного
ліцею і від маленької сільської школи
але ви можете рахувати приріст ця
сільська Школа може дати значно більше
дитині тому що вона з дитини з малими
негативними або від'ємними навіть
показниками успіху надає можливість
дитині отримати середній результат І це
дуже добре якщо дитина з маленької школи
або з промислового району де ніхто
ніколи не здобував вищу освіту де нікому
не цікаво освіта в принципі і де всі
орієнтуються на професію батьків яка
може бути такою що не передбачає вищої
освіти
то якщо дитина захотіла цієї вищої
освіти і змогла вступити навіть з
невисоким балом ЗНО це перемога школи і
про це така система би нам повідомила
що нам би така система дала ну власне
вона би дала нам можливість отримувати
інформацію і вона це могла би робити
якщо б у нас в принципі були
ідентифікатори унікальні ідентифікатори
кожного учня кожного закладу освіти
Тобто нам потрібна окрім системи
тестування нам потрібно система бази
даних де ці результати були би
логічними і адекватними також вона би
нам дала інформацію про навчальні
досягнення учнів з ключових навчальних
предметів відповідно поступу і ми би
могли чесно батькам говорити і собі
говорити про те Чого досягає дитина на
кожному етапі і які на що впливає ці
результати Ще нам дала можливість
система показати вплив кожної окремої
школи так звану в Польщі додому освітню
вартість тих
внесків так кожного закладу який є
чого би нам не дала ця система ще вона
би нам не дала можливості порівнювати
себе з іншими країнами тому що це була
би унікальна Вітчизняна система але ця
система не дозволила би нам говорити про
те що ми умовно відстаємо чи
випереджаємо когось з математики або
соціально емоційного навчання для цього
безперечно в цій системі
стандартизованих оцінювань або системі
Великих осцінювань Нам потрібні
міжнародні дослідження наразі є
міжнародне дослідження Піза і є запрошую
вас бути частиною презентації цього
дослідження результатів цього
дослідження 22-го року 5 грудня цього
року 5 грудня ми покажемо які реальні є
втрати з ключових компетентностей в
українських учнів
також є звичайно інший дослідження
зокрема і дослідження так званих м'яких
насправді твердих у женевичок таке як
міжнародне дослідження соціальної
емоційних навичок це дуже важливе
дослідження тому що за твердими
навичками часто ми не бачимо того що
дуже буде значуща для дитини для її
поступу в реальному житті і це
дослідження дозволило б нам це робити І
власне ще в нас є прекрасна своє
національне дослідження яке вимірює
результати навчальних досягнень учнів 4
класі з математики і мови невдовзі в
цьому дослідженні буде ще
природничо-наукова грамотність і
Наступного року ми його проводимо ми вже
маємо результати карантину і ми знаємо
як два роки дистанційної форми вплинули
на наших учнів і результати невтішні
І власне Ми би також сприяли в цій
системі створені і утворені локальних
моніторингів якості які ви відповідали
на потреби конкретних управлінців
конкретного регіону в кожного вчителя і
в кожної вчительки може бути своя
потреба і цю потребу можна
задовольнити створивши локальні
моніторинги які ви його який би їй
відповідали Ну а останнє І найважливіше
Напевно що я хотіла сказати це те що
освітнє оцінювання - Це важлива частина
системи але ніколи не потрібно очікувати
на те що вони самі вдосконалять вам вашу
систему освіти це інструмент Це не його
мета ви не можете сподіватися вивчити
математику запровадивши тестування з
математики ви не можете сподіватися
вивчити історію України за впровадивши
тестування з історії України це
інструмент правильний важливий але сам
по собі він нічого не робить
лопата це супер Якщо ви не поклали
картоплю в лунку яка була супер яка була
супер лопата не була картопелька там Не
виросте
Дякую всім нашим спікерам Ми дуже
верхнерівне в обговорили ті напрямки
системи яку так важко реформувати адже
вона стосується дуже великої кількості
дітей і яких Вона і так само і дорослих
якщо ми говоримо про освітян говоримо
про вчителів я нагадаю що наша панель
продовжується за думаю хвилин 15-20
темою підвищення кваліфікації вчителів
ви зможете приєднатися Якщо цікавить вас
ваша тема Я ще раз дякую нашим спікерам
Я дуже вірю що це справжній рестарт і це
оновлення системи яка яке збереже все
найкраще що в ній було і допоможе
виправити ті помилки які були допущені
раніше оновлення системи в тому числі
покликання краще я сподіваюся що воно
буде продовжуватися надалі Дякую всім і
до наступної панелі
Добрий день колеги
знову вас побачити ми в онлайні
можна попросити що мою колегу запустити
тому що вона буде
Оксана Дегтярьова вона також стоїть там
На вході
Це чудово
у нас здається не дозволяє зараз
налаштування не дозволяє показати нічого
на екрані перевірте будь ласка
організатори
ми не будемо показувати я не буду
показувати слайди Але я думаю що можливо
слайди показувати ми хотіли показати
платформу власне
живи але напевно я не знаю якщо настав
хтось чує
колег
один два три зараз Мене добре чути
Так зараз
Я б не сказав що добре але чуємо А ви
нас чуєте бачити
хотілось би зрозуміти чи буде видно наше
зображення Під час всієї дискусії чи в
нас будуть виводити власне на наші
частини
так Доброго дня Мене звати Роман зараз
хвилинку ми протестуємо у вас буде видно
конкретно той хто розмовляє буде
виводитись на екран тобто Протягом цього
часу
відключати так
пан Романе Скажіть будь ласка я планував
під час там відповіді на одне зі своїх
запитань от з другого аккаунта який
зайшов таким Ukraine робити демонстрацію
на слайді про показати
[музика]
веб-портал Поки я буду розповідати
репортаж тобто відео у вас буде так я
розумію ну це буде не відео це буде
виводитися сторінка фактично браузера і
моя колега буде її гортати Поки я буду
розповідати ну Якщо зможете поширити то
в принципі не проблема ми зможемо
вивести на екрани
а демонстрації екрана заборонена
організаторами тому вам треба якось
демонстрацію екрану я включу давайте
ласка обом якщо можна
Скажіть будь ласка а ми будемо бачити
залу чи модератора дивіться я так
звичайно я вам виведу із залу тобто
зараз хвилинку отак ви будете бачити
грубо кажучи і так буде видно клас
[музика]
о котрій ми будемо починати зорієнтуйте
будь ласка
Поки що так
хвилин 15 орієнтовно але будемо
орієнтуватися по факту того що Зараз
чекаємо
Так є трошки затримка у нас
розберемося вас добре чути добре видно
це тільки організатор може зробити пані
елементи
піклується про це Все буде добре
клікнути можна на наших на наших
профілях близько учасників і дати дозвіл
зробити президента
Так зараз на хвилину на хвилинку я
відключуся буквально
А я піду візьму таблетки від кашлю я
застуджена одужуйте
це неприємно коли треба виступати і
кашляєш зрозумів
А ну У нас є ще хвилин 15 тому ми можемо
Поки ви будете в такому режимінку
один два
шість чули від вас
розбірливо воно було
так колеги якщо вона чуєте ми не бачимо
що ви активували можливість
демонструвати екран і будемо дуже вдячні
якщо вона з'явиться дякую
1 2 3
чуємо Так Олександр А скажіть будь ласка
декілька слів так щоб я перевірив добре
звук щоб у вас було чути і в принципі
так давайте ми ради вас вітати з Харкова
чи добре ви мене чуєте чи гарна картинка
Так дуже добре вас чути видно теж дуже
добре
Нагадую що просимо же активувати нам
демонстрацію
Зараз ми це зробимо
і Олена будь ласка теж скажіть декілька
слів щоб я вас почув щоб все було вже в
порядку скажу
на вас теж дуже добре чути
Так дякую
щось по часу Зрозуміло Коли починаємо
Поки що ні підготовка йде зараз я вас
орієнтую за декілька хвилин
добре добре
ну зараз активують
пані Олена можемо скористатися
очікуванням поки
подумати що ми можемо з вами робити
цікавий разом
Я думаю що нам треба просто зібратися
провести окремо зустріч обов'язково
обов'язково і подумати У нас сьогодні
пару слів скажу про це у нас з'являються
нові
я бачу кілька точок дотику я якщо можна
пані Олена Напишіть мені вашу електронну
адресу в чат і якщо вам не стане в
наступному тижні давайте закладуємо
годинку
поспілкуватися спокійно нам показали що
там всередині і ми подумали що ми могли
би разом робити тут
Тому що тут точно є синергія за двері і
оцей
співпрацювали і тим більше що тут є
так наші спікери вже чують правильно
пані Оксана пан Юрій пан Юрій пан Юрій
канал нуль значить не працює пані Оксана
шпиніть будь ласка
чи ввімкніться диван чуєте вже супер
так
я чую
але я чую
добре колеги всім вітання Я так розумію
що всі зібралися
бачу хто посміхається значить працює
Я думаю що мене чутно нашим спікером так
і мене чутно підійміть руку хто чує
добре
решту сподіваюсь вже чує рук було багато
тому ми будемо розпочинати друзі Дякую
всім хто з нами на сцені всім хто в залі
Мене звати Зої Литвин і я очолюю
громадську спілку освіторія і на
сьогодні чудова тема яку я маю честь
модерувати палітра професій можливостей
професійного розвитку освітян і власне
всі колеги які роблять великі важливі
справи У цій галузі ми коли вчора
позавчора говорили про панель про ці
питання і проблеми які хотіли
проговорити Насправді всі відмітили що
українські вчителі демонструють власним
прикладом ось цю концепцію Life long
Learning якою ми маємо навчати дітей а
для того маєм пропагувати і
демонструвати самі і дивувалися як
власне перші тижні після
повномасштабного вторгнення щойно
освітянам вдалося відновити освітній
процес стабілізувати і себе
стабілізуватися разом з колегами їхні
найперші запити були про навчання як
навчати в цих умовах як підтримувати
себе як підтримувати дітей подекуди їх
родини як робити дистанційку ще краще і
так далі тому ми про це сьогодні
поговоримо з гордістю за українських
освітян і всіх тих провайдерів Так можна
сказати хто
допомагає навчатися і бути ще кращими
задля українських дітей у нас чудова
компанія з нами Павло Кузьмович очільник
Львівського інституту підвищення
педагогічної післядипломної освіти іппо
з нами паніжанна севастянова очільниця
освітніх проектів британської ради для
навчання вчителів англійської мови з
нами пані Ольга Донець яка є
координаторкою очільницею ініціативи
демократична школа центру Берген Да з
нами також нагрічена яка заступниця
директора ман малої Академії Наук з
методичної роботи і відповідно з усіх
навчань вчителів з нами також пані
Оксана Рома з фундації Lego яка
координує чолі освітньої ініціативи цієї
фундації з нами Юрій гайдученко Мій
колега Юрій очолює тренінговий центр
спілки освіторія всі напрямки з навчання
вчителів і з нами ще сьогодні два чудові
експерти і спікери які знаходяться в
онлайні це є Олександр елькін не знаючи
нам Олександра покажет але ви точно його
почуєте ми вже тестували зв'язок
Олександр знайомий вам за чудову
організацію едкемп і він є Голова Ради
едкемпу на сьогодні і також з нами пані
Олена Бех яка є
експертом з людського капіталу і
координаторам проекти ітів європейського
фонду освіти в освітніх інноваціях і
сьогодні вона власне про них буде
говорити і я думаю що судячи з обличчя в
залі почати нам варто з такої короткої
самопрезентації зі знайомства щоб всі ті
хто дивляться в ефірі ці хто присутні
тут могли зрозуміти яка Ось та палітра
можливостей навчання освітян і я попрошу
кожного зі спікерів Коротко розказати на
чому ваша організація фокусується в
навчанні освітян Які Ті здобутки якими
ви на сьогодні особливо пишаєтеся
пропоную почати з пана Юрія і рухатися
географічному порядку
Юрій нечутно нам потрібна технічна
допомога
спробуйте кнопок
так вже так вітання Шановні колеги
Дякуємо зацікаюсь до власне питання
професійного розвитку вчителів це
насправді дуже важлива коли ми говоримо
про
послідовність реформи нової української
школи і про те власне як має сьогодні
відбуватися підвищення професійної
компетентності професійних
компетентностей вчителів громадська
спілка освіторія тісно вивчає власне
запити від вчителів як вони хочуть
навчатися у яких форматах вони хочуть
навчатися які напрямки є пріоритетними
протягом минулого року громадська спілка
освіторія тренінговий центр онлайн новий
онлайн нова платформа у університет
розроблена спеціально для дистанційних
форматів підтримки вчителів охопили
більше 80 тисяч вчителів на основі
різних курсів вебінарів І це дає змогу
власне констатувати те що
основні запити вчителів і основний запит
на сьогодні
це практичність
практичне спрямування
будь-яких курсів чи то коротеньких
вебінарів чи то довготривалих курсів
тому протягом минулого року попри власне
усі ті виклики які мають освітяни Нам
вдалося провести навчання тренерів для
базової середньої освіти це 300 тренерів
які провели цикли
цикли тренінгів в різних регіонах І
власне це розроблений курс для вчителів
які
починають масову практику пілотування
нового державного стандарту це курс нова
українська школа
базова середня освіта Сьогодні можемо
сказати про те що це 12 тисяч
користувачів 12 тисяч вчителів які
успішно завершили цей курс і Сьогодні
мають такі методичні і педагогічні
підґрунтя для того щоб якісно
запроваджувати на своїх уроках
новий державний стандарт поряд з тим
громадська спілка освіторія також
переймається
тим наскільки вчителям Вчителі можуть
сьогодні здійснювати
соціальну підтримку учнів у складних
умовах ми розробили декілька курсів це
курс реальне навчання
курс реальне навчання та курс
розуміє який допомагає вчителям саме
налагодити роботу в укриттях роботу з
учнями які потребують особливої уваги у
цей дуже важкий час для усіх нас поряд
система знаємо з реальних відгуків
вчителів що вони очікують такого
глобального практичного занурення
Вибачте розкажу що це трошки довше ніж
візитівка напрямки навчання і досягнення
Мені здається що ви розказали багато але
пропоную
спікером так добре тоді пані Оксана
коротенько про те які напрямки навчання
освітян пропонує фундація Лего в Україні
і які досягнення на сьогодні є якими
особливо пишаєтесь дякую пані зорі за
запитання вітання усім незламним
українцям українськими освітянам і от я
дивлюся на обличчі розумію що Точно з
половиною з вас Ми вже дуже добре
знайомі багато співпрацюємо але для всіх
людей які дивляться на нас онлайн як
фундація Lego ми присутні в Україні з
2010 року і такою особливістю
унікальністю можливо нашої роботи в
Україні те що ми данської корпоративною
фундацією Які спрямовуємо кошти які
отримує бізнес 25% цих коштів на
Науковій і освітні проєкти в різних
куточках світу зокрема і в Україні в
Україні наш підхід ґрунтується на
співпраці з формальною системою освіти і
цей дошкілля і початкова і базова школа
шостий клас але ми стоїмо на засадах
того що все що ми робимо не важливо коли
ми завершимо свою діяльність в Україні
має залишитися у формальній системі тому
для нас надзвичайно помічними і
інструментальними в будь-якій нашій
діяльності є інститути післядипломної
освіти через які на сьогодні ми
реалізуємо і спекуси для вчителів
початкової школи діяльність не підхід у
початковій школі наскрізний вимір і
скільки вже було навчань для вчителів
початкової школи про яке Ми сьогодні ще
говоритимемо пізніше те що буде І
реалізуємо програми психосоціальної
підтримки які зараз є на часі те що вже
стає невід'ємною нашою реальністю і
головне Хочу зазначити чому ми стоїмо на
засадах діяльності
підходу сьогодні час в Україні для
інновацій і дуже хочеться щоб ми
використали правильно і порозумному цей
час і дивлячись на ті Дослідження які є
на сьогодні у світі нещодавно було
проаналізовано інститутом брукінь 3
тисячі інновації в освіті то з них 70%
використовують ігровий і діяльнісний
підхід тому я думаю що в нас є всі шанси
і ми відкриті до співпраці з будь-якою
інституцією Державної комунальної форми
власності школи садочки інститути
продовжуємо рух далі
дякую пані Анна
Доброго дня Мене чути Так
отже Доброго дня шановна освітянська
спільнота Я представляю національний
центр мала академія дуже багато хто знає
нас Як тих хто на проводить фінальний
етап конкурсу захисту мала академія і
знають нас лише по цьому але е це ману
це не лише конкурс захист це щорічно
майже 100 заходив для дітей різних
навчальних змагальних і так далі І також
хочу розповісти вам про те як ми вже
протягом чотирьох років працюємо для
освітян і з освітянами коли ми починали
цей напрям в нас було 10 програм різних
напрямів Це була математика хімія і так
далі але на сьогоднішній день в нас
розрослися наші напрями до Понад 12
напрямів предметних і також в нас є
безліч програм щодо цифрової
компетентності емоційної цінностей і так
далі Коли ми починали в нас було 10 000
учасників за рік Сьогодні в нас цифра за
рік наближується до 40-3 тисяч і це
говорить про те що ми дійсно не даємо
гарні послуги які поширюються по всій
Україні хочу сказати про те що зазвичай
до нас приходили лише позашкільники але
останніх два роки напевно завдяки тому
що наші гуртки працюють також в закладах
загальної середньої освіти до нас дуже
приходять багато вчителів-предметників
тому Я запрошую всіх до співпраці щоб не
затримувати час хочу лише сказати що
якщо ми повернемося назад справа в нас є
наш стенд там безпосередньо можете
ознайомитися з нашими пропозиціями і
також звертаю вашу увагу на те що якщо
зайти на наш сайт в нас є Ось така
невеличка брошура яка розповідає про всі
всі наші напрями тобто якщо у вас
цікавить будь-який наш напрям Заходьте
на наш сайт і побачите будь-які програми
щодо співпраці з нами то я хочу сказати
що як колеги працюють з інститутами
післядипломної освіти Ми поки що з ними
не працюємо але ми працюємо з
регіональними центрами про розвитку які
зараз відкриваються в кожній громаді на
сьогодні на співпраця з львівською
громадами є з тернопільськими маленькими
громадами містечковими і з одеськими
тому я думаю що будь-хто Хто захоче з
нами співпрацювати він знайде цю
можливість Дякую не затримую
друзі а вже чую Вибачайте це магія
мікрофону передбачити її дуже складно
пані Анна до вашого коментаря про те що
Ви поки не працюєте зппо у вас є
сьогодні чудова можливість розпочати цю
співпрацю А я передаю слово пані Олі щоб
представити центр вергелента в Україні
ініціативу демократична школа
так не чутно спробуйте покрутити його в
мене спрацювало
Спробуйте ще раз Мені здається Доброго
дня
Та я би хотіла сказати що вся наша
велика команда програми демократична
школа яка знаходиться і в Осло в центрі
імені веергеланда і яка знаходиться тут
в Україні з першого дня нової
української школи ми вірили в силу цієї
реформи і головним цінності цієї реформи
І тому ми одразу подумали як ми можемо
інтегрувати ці пані Олю у вас мікрофон
працює так собі Якщо можна я вам передам
Свідок
Так Дуже дякую і ми з першого дня думала
як же можна ми
втілити ці цінності в наше освітні
продукти задля того щоб ці цінності
безпосередньо дійшли до вчителів і до
дітей заради кого взагалі ця реформа і
втілюється і так з'явилася ідея
створення масових онлайн-курсів маємо
цілу серію онлайн-курсів 30 кроків до
нової української школи виховуємо
громадянина вони розташовані у нас на
прометеусі на сьогодні вже більше ніж
150 тисяч освітян пройшли ці масові
курси на платформі і продовжуються
робити а також хочеться сказати що такої
родзинкою програмою демократична школа є
фасилітовані онлайн-курси а це про
якість
тому що це курси такі змішані коли люди
навчаються синхронно і асинхронно і вони
безпосередньо частину матеріалу
проходять на навчальних платформах а
частину матеріалу Вони мають
безпосередньо зустрічі синхронні з
авторами авторами курсу Да коли вони
зустрічаються можуть завдати запитання
створюється така площадка для діалогу і
теж вже більше ніж тисяча освітян
пройшли наші фасилітовані курси їх
напрямок дуже різноманітний головним
чином це формування і розвиток
громадянських компетентності також це
курси які направлені на підтримку
директорів і адміністрації школи - це
курси присвячені учнівському
самоврядуванням Зараз я в мене буде
можливість сказати про нові курси які
будуть зараз стартувати з нового
навчального року також хочу сказати що у
нас дуже потужна велика команда яка може
собі дозволити
робити дай проводити ці фасилітовані
курси тому що маємо велику мережу
тренерів і тренерах 70+ по всій Україні
які також є авторами авторками цих
курсів І тому ми можемо охоплювати
велику кількість осві Тян тому
будемо дуже раді бачити всіх на наших
курсах про які я думаю ще будемо
можливість ще трошки розказати тримаємо
інтригу
це пані жані Давайте спробуємо чи
мікрофон буде краще працювати чи чутно
мене чутно навіть без перепон прекрасно
Вітаю поважних гостей в цій студії також
всю нашу онлайн аудиторію хочу сказати
що для мене це дуже велика честь
сьогодні розказати про програми
професійного розвитку яку впроваджує
британська Рада в Україні британська
Рада в Україні працює вже більше 30
років і багато освітян і наша цільова
аудиторія це вчителі англійської мови
знають про наші програми ми працювали з
університетами педагогічними в програмі
вчитель нового покоління ми працювали з
інститутами іппо коли ми впроваджували
ключові уміння і також створювали групи
професійної майстерності по всій країні
ми також допомогли натренувати велику
горду агентів змін які потім тренували
вчителів англійської мови початкової
школи і нуш - це нова українська школа
реформа для нас була Must як ми кажемо з
підтримки і ми працюємо з вчителями
англійської мови самого початку під час
пандемії британська рада запропонувала
вчителям перейти до платформи ми
називаємо її Онлайн тітчиком Unity тобто
громада вчителів спільнота вчителів на
онлайн-платформі де Ми продовжуємо
пропонувати програми професійного
розвитку для вчителів 5-6 клас більш ніж
7 тисяч вчителів пройшли нашу програму
підготовки
нещодавно ми запропонували нову програму
підготовки вчителів для 7-9 класів з
основними фокусами медійна грамотність
використання цифрових технологій Я
сподіваюся що в мене буде ще можливість
розказати вам про нашу
реакцію і дуже успішний проект який ми
розпочали зразу після початку
повномасштабного штуршення І як ми це
зробили ми дуже пишаємося тим що
Протягом цього року якраз Минулого року
серпні перший тренінг провели у Польщі і
Протягом цього року більше ніж 1500
вчителів побували вже на нашому тренінгу
і мали можливість поїхати і розказати
про основні моменти і допомогу вчителям
і дітям у себе в школах
які цифри як для організації яка
фокусується На одних предметниках саме з
англійської мови
пане Павла Я не знаю чим новим ви
зможете здивувати аудиторію як очільник
одного з іппо тому що все ж таки це
найдавніший державний головний гравець
підвищення
кваліфікації освітян так знову зник мій
звук Дякую
чуєте все так але
так
чутно Добре бо я себе не чую але ми
будемо Я б хотіла запитати враховуючи що
ось цю нову останню вашу таку освітню
посаду в цілому калейдоскопі роботи в
освіті з різних з різних сторін і
організацій чим особливо ви пишаєтесь за
останні три роки саме на цій посаді що
вдалося зробити нового
Вітаю Шановні колеги я тут представляю
інститути і я би хотів почати відповідь
строки сторони з двох подяк перше подяка
колегам народі особливо
англійською мовою Ми не займаємося
братишкансом займається інститут
німецької займається все краще від них
ми нічого не зробимо і Дякуємо за те що
ви це робите Lego foundation які так
само проводить і тренінги мало того що й
дало чим проводити тренінгу в кожну
школу і щей цеглинок і плейбокси і це
все розказував Це просто супер те що
було іншим колегам також Дякуємо а друга
подяка за те що все-таки на цю панель
включили
представників ну зокрема мене як
директора інституту післядипломної
освіти тому що розумієте мені отаке було
порівняння Ви працюєте з цим людьми яких
ви казали які більше мотивовані яких ви
відбираєте банкетик і так далі наше
завдання інститутів
захисник працювати зі всіма ми
зобов'язані з Законом працювати зі всіма
педагогічними працівниками області і ми
не можемо нікому відмовити вже в
залежності від фінансової ситуації
області ти можеш мати курси 30-ї години
тому що матиметься ми годині ти можеш
мати на всі роки ти можеш мати там на
два роки з 5 років і так далі І так далі
Тож як коли складається з фінансами і в
цьому різниця є наш інститутів і ваш
прекрасний проєктів це призвано те саме
Яке тут наскільки шкіл 10 там 15 які
готують перемосим міжнародних олімпіадом
чи з математики чи з фізики і є
загальноосвітні школи це такий як наші
інститути які працюють зі всіма
мотивований і не мотивованими але але та
роль Яку мають інститути вона чітко
звучала на попередні панелі коли говорив
заступник Міністра Андрій Сташків про те
що є проти субвенції і знову І про що
Говори міністр
16-19 років Лілія Гриневич тобто тоді
коли ми запроваджували ну з початковій
школі і всі ті тренери Всі сюди помалу
робити вони всі йшли через інститути
післядипломної педагогічної освіти є
ціна наши Агенти змін це і тренери нуш і
є це питання супривізія яку треба
відновлювати тому щоби з цієї супровізії
зміни дуже важко важко впроваджується
треба допомагати робити і тому я дякую
що вона запросили Бо насправді інститути
Вони мають і в законі це ми прописували
цей 1% на підвищення кваліфікації це та
інституція яка реалізує державну
політику в освіті і реалізує зі всіма
мотивованими і не вмотивованими
результати звичайно не такі як у вас
результат У нас є різні тому що як є
різні учні в класі так само В нас є
різні учні ну наші слухачі є в групах
тому Дякуємо і співпрацюємо від цього
тільки ви бере освіта а
Особливо ми це старалися робили при
попередній команді Міністерства зараз це
легше робити і я вам скажу що якщо не
буде по силу з міністерства якщо не буде
цієї провідної ролі яку зараз знову
починає брати Міністерство то на місцях
дуже дуже важко реалізовувати ті інші
речі тому що зміна іде тяжко і якщо ніби
зверху Там хтось собі не кажуть робити
зміни А ми є на рівні Ми не є в мене є
керівний орган ми органи який допомагає
який навчає надихає розвиває вчителів
для їхнього розвитку Тому це буде важко
робити тому працюємо в різних нам всіх
напрямках зі всіма категоріями мали
пріоритети свої маємо
Дякую
інститути - це про доступність освіти
для освітян
другий
блок у нас буде якраз таки більш
проблемний Мені б хотілося зануритися в
нуш але це варто зробити після наступних
наших двох спікерів і я б хотіла
передати слово якраз Олександру який в
онлайні сьогодні до нас приєднується
Олександр ви з нами
почуємо і будемо раді коротенько якраз
почути про фокус організація ткемп в
Україні
Дорогі колеги давайте ніколи не
сумніватися у тому що в маленьку групу
людей які мислять та віддані справі
насправді здатні змінити світ і Це єдине
що його коли-небудь змінювали Я вітаю
вас з незламного Харкова Я дякую за цю
можливість бути з вами онлайн і коли я
розповідаю про цю унікальну місію яка
буквально як в хорошому сенсі вірус
поширилося Всім світом рухи кемп я
згадуюсь словами маргаритмід з яких я
розпочав бо вони дуже добре ілюструють
як ми об'єднуємо освітяни і допомагаємо
їм зростати зокрема в Україні скільки
йдеться сучасна війна стільки існує наш
рух у кожній другій українській школі
сьогодні є в середньому 3 кемпери та Ед
кемперки Загалом у нашій спільноті понад
40 тисяч освітян Ukraine часто
сприймають як Айсберг тобто бачить
тільки його верхівку і нас знають як тих
організовує події в форматі
неконференції з 2015 року ми провели 8
національних і 234 регіональні заходи Я
дуже пишаюся що в останній
повновоєнний рік ми організували з
місцевим спільноти 38 подій але це
тільки верхівка бо Ми займаємося
підтримкою реформи нової української
школи впроваджуємо продуктивні ідеї за
кордону і маємо антикризовий ініціативи
часів ковіду та у місяці
повномасштабного вторгнення так якщо
разом порахувати наші різноманітні
програми підвищення кваліфікації від
українських міжнародних експертів а
також в рамках нашої академії яка працює
за принципом рівнем тільки за останній
рік з нами зросли понад 20 тисяч освітян
наші суперсили у нас їх чимало я так
вважаю вони усі пов'язані з тим що
написано у цій важливій книжечці у
концепції нової української школи те що
я називаю доданою
я скажу тільки про дві з них перше
стосується соціальної емоційних навичок
і наша програма
соціально-емоційно-політичного навчання
в якому мріємо привести до кожної
української школи це міжнародне
моніторингове дослідження досер від
організації економічного співробітництва
і розвитку це також і платформа для
подолання освітніх втрат розривів повір
про яку сьогодні з різних сцену говорять
де Також ми будемо спиратися на розвиток
цих навичок і друга наша суперсила я так
скажу трохи інтригуючий перед моїм
наступним виступом це в принципі зміна
того як Вчительську підвищує свою
кваліфікацію
через запровадження так званого 3D
підходу що за 3D скажу в другій частині
Дорогі колеги до серпневих подій
традиційно ми випускаємо наше звернення
з усіма родзинками можливостями Я
запрошую слідкувати за нашим
онлайн-ресурсами відвідувати наш
оновлений веб-сайт організації де все
зібрано і дуже тішуся що багато спільнот
роблять серпневі конференції власне у
форматі неконференції
Дякую Олександре і
слово розказати про 3D навчання буде
точно А мені здається перед тим як
рухатись вже до другої частини питань
хочеться поговорити з пані Оленою пані
Олена у вас це чудова посада це є
освітній інновації в освіті і в навчанні
це все що стосується людського капіталу
і ви працюєте в прекрасній організації
європейські фонду освіти ви на Вістрі
тихоновацій ми будемо вдячні там тепер
бачать чогось ту палітру яка присутня в
Україні Від головних державних гравців
доступних для всіх до якихось нішевих і
більше великих організацій з
громадського сектору
можете нам назвати якісь сьогодні є
основні тренди тому що ми все одно
працюємо зараз в контексті в парадигмі
повномасштабної війни ми про це будемо
говорити але перед тим хотілося
подивитися що відбувається в Європі і
які головні напрямки
форми і тренди у підвищенні кваліфікації
освітян на сьогодні
Я дякую за можливість приєднатися до
цієї прекрасної наради і я хочу сказати
що сьогоднішні ранковий початок
новин наради справи на мене величезне
враження
дуже потужний І абсолютно не віриться в
те що це все відбувається в умовах
повного вторгнення
Російської Федерації і для нас як для
європейського фонду освіти надзвичайно
велика честь і важливий обов'язок
співпрацювати з Україною нелегкий час і
ми підтримуємо загальний такий бойовий і
енергійний і креативний посил який іде
від уряду і зокрема Звучав у виступі в
віце-прем'єр-міністра і міністра і
голови комітету Верховної Ради і Цей
підхід звичайно дуже добре відповідає
духові того що ми в своїй роботі
ідентифікуємо Як найважливіші напрями
роботи з освітянами з підтримки їхньої
нелегкої праці і зокрема розвитку їхніх
компетентностей і створення умов для
їхнього їхнього успішного ефективного
професійного професійної діяльності Я
хочу сказати що я як би сказала
координую напрям напрям інновації в
освіті навчальній викладанні і за моїми
плечима величезна команда як на наш на
наш наш скажімо масштаб 13 експертів які
кожних з них є дуже цікавою особистістю
і вони об'єднані команди яка називається
крейзією тому те що я буду говорити це є
результат роботи тому що ця команда
почала декілька років тому назад своє
існування із аналізу основної світової
літератури і зокрема це були академічні
дослідження ми зробили велику підбірку
різних досліджень і проаналізували
декілька у цьому п'ять сфер в якій є
найважливішими в інноваціях в навчанні і
викладанні і зокрема однією з цих була
е-е була профілювання чи
окреслення тих основних характеристик
якими має володіти е-е сучасний вчитель
XXI століття і тут я хотіла теж
приєднатися до тих
меседжів до тих значить закликів які
звучали в сьогоднішній в першій половині
сьогоднішнє засідання це те що вчитель
потрібно створити умови звичайно не має
бути креативним і він має бути сміливим
і сміливість приходить із відчуттям
своєї власної компетентності Як сьогодні
говорив один із учнів на одній
попередніх сесії що вчителі не
почуваються інколи впевненими в
використанні скажімо цифрових технологій
або в інших ситуаціях і ми вже з вами
трохи підзабули що перед цим були два
роки півтора обов'язково йду і коли всі
учителі були поставлені перед поставлені
перед величезним тестом на те чи зможуть
Вони одразу перейти в онлайн чи вони
зможуть перейти в навчання з
використанням цифрових технологій і ця
ці виклики продовжилися набагато
сильнішому вигляді під час
повномасштабного вторгнення тому я б
хотіла сказати декілька ключових
моментів перше - це
зараз розмиваються рамки між тим хто є
вчитель хто вчить і хто навчається Тому
що кожний вчитель став учнем
впродовж життя і кожний учень стає
керівником чи управлінцем менеджером
свого власного навчання своєї кар'єрною
траєкторії і тому роль вчителя для
безпечно полягає в тому щоб підтримати
оцей те що називається норми розривен
або підхід який базується на повазі до
вибору і свідомого
свідомої реалізації візії кожного учня
Чи кожна людина яка навчається Чи це
будуть
молоді люди чи це будуть дорослі які
потрапили в східні умови повернулися з
фронту або ті які втратили місце роботи
повинні терміново знайти засоби до
існування і продовжити повноцінне життя
Тому перше це звичайно зміна оцих от
стандартів звичайно ж розмиваються дуже
сильно останні роки
бар'єри між формальною освітою
неформальним навчанням і зараз важливий
результат Важливо щоб наша професійна
робота полягала в тому що складні моделі
складні технологічні рішення складні
методики які стоять за лаштунками
про педагогічних досліджень
реалізувалися в простих рішеннях які
підтримують вчителя і я зокрема скажу
про два таких інструменти які ми можемо
надати для України і вже готуємо їх для
реалізації в Україні але з одного боку
звичайно цікаві виклики ковіду і
ситуації звичайно для нас вже стали
звичними але всі перебуваємо як не було
сказано в стані величезного стресу
постійного ті хто знаходяться в Україні
Ті хто в цьому обставинах знаходяться
поза є межами і тому виступають на
перший план деякі
характеристики вчителя які дуже важливі
На цей момент зокрема Я б сказала для
нас дуже важливо
підтримувати
адаптивність і ініціативність вчителя
тому що вчителю потрібні ті самі
наскрізні уміння які вчитель має
розвивати згідно державного стандарту
України учня ці самі ключові
компетентності такі як критичне мислення
такі як
підтримка партій сепаративного підходу
розуміння роботи в команді і усвідомлене
навчання тобто навчання з
відповідно певної візії Отже
адаптивність в тому числі
підприємливість Як ми знаємо це одна із
ключових
это дуже важлива і досить на основі
реального життя
дуже важливо розвивати
вміння просувати сталий розвиток і
підходи до інклюзивні підходи в освіті
для вчителя як я сказав вміння працювати
в команді і залучати колег і залучати
всіх учасників процесу до нього навчання
впродовж життя здатність до
саморефлексії і здатність до
самооцінювання тобто те що є зокрема
частиною формою формувального оцінювання
і так само стосовно самого вчителя Ну і
звичайно цифрова компетентність у
зв'язку з тим що мій час закінчується Я
залишив назвала два інструменти і про
які ми можемо сказати пізніше і я покажу
їх на екрані це в першу чергу ми
розробили модель яка називається релі
натискайте
Screen І ми тоді всі зможемо побачити
працюємо
я вимкнула таймер просто в мене стояв
таймер Так отже це модель рейдів Вона
знаходиться на нашому веб-сайті ітф
значить він називається модель реві і
тут перераховані
сфери
основних характеристик сучасного вчителя
XXI століття вона інтерактивна там
можливо зайти всередину цієї моделі і
вона клікати і можна побачити всі
компоненти та перераховані різні
відкритори і там є
зокрема різні практики які ілюструють ті
чи інші сфери діяльності вчителя тобто
нею можна користуватися при створенні
стандарту вчителя професійного можна
користуватися при розробці програм
професійного розвитку вчителів і зокрема
вчителів можуть користуватися нею для
саморозвитку і цю модель ми переклали
вже українською мовою Ми зараз працюємо
в міністерством Освіти над тим щоб
застосувати її до тих задач які я
перерахувала і до деяких інших І ще я
назву ще один інструмент Це зараз одну
секунду Так я покажу це те що стосується
вчителів конкретно він називається
скасол А я зроблю анонс що скафанд
власне перекладається українською мовою
ці картки і наприкінці вересня вже
будуть доступні
знаєте про рейді що реві базується на
основі аналізу 50 різних рамок
професійних стандартів вчителів в різних
країнах світу рамок компетентностей і
всіх інших інструментів і методичних
розробок які академічне Дослідження які
мали до цього відношення там дуже
глибоке глибоке підґрунтя зараз ви
бачите я сподіваюсь що бачите
але буквально давайте 30 секунд
найцікавіше про це інструмент скажу лише
що це набір карт які може використати
вчитель переплануванні навчального
процесу зокрема при плануванні і дизайні
одного року чи цілої програми ці 100 дві
картки містять у собі невір карток які
дозволяють розкласти глоні елементи
навчального процесу і ви виділити їх там
є бібліотека куди входять всі рамки
європейські ключових компетентностей
зокрема
Entercom дічком рамка
сталого розвитку і рамка вміння
навчатися впродовж життя і зокрема там є
набір карток із
наскрізними компетентностями які
показують яким чином можна застосувати
інтегрований підхід до формування
результатів навчання також методи
формувального оцінювань і методологія
методологія навчання
ключовим компетентностям цей набір
фізичні картки 102 штучки в коробочці ми
зараз почали перекладати їх українською
мовою Ми зробимо версію яку можна буде
роздрукувати і розрізати в школі або в
будь-яких умовах і за кілька місяців
надрукуємо професійно картки які роздамо
в пілотні школи для того щоб вони могли
почати навчальний процес для вчителів і
щоб вчителі могли скористатися при
роботі з учнями Дякую за увагу і дуже
рада буде будь-яким
паросткам співпраці які можуть
народитися з цієї
панелі всі сесії і дуже я бажаю всім
Перемоги і слава Україні Дякуємо пані
Олена це надважливі інструменти і за те
що занурили нас в світові тренди друзі
переходимо до проблемного етапу і
хочеться так скласти пазл найбільших
викликів для українських вчителів в
їхній самоосвіті для освітян і Пані
Жанна хотілося б напевно з вас почати ми
говорили про Чим живе світ на яких нових
навичках фокусуємося як рухаємося у
світі та навчанні А є наші реалії і є
якісь першочергові виклики які на там
бувають найнижчому рівні піраміди Маслоу
Якщо говорити про діяльність вашої
команди от з навчання навіть вчителів
англійської як вона змінилася після
повномасштабної війни Чи ви от на тому
етапі разом з Європою Чи ви зараз
фокусуєтеся на вздовж всім інших речах
дуже цікаво сталося з нами тому що я
говорила вже ми під час пандемії
перейшли на онлайн-платформу розробили
про пілотували дуже цікавий курс для
вчителів щоб підтримати нову українську
школу і саме на початку
повномасштабного вторгнення на нашій
платформі навчалося 3 тисячі вчителів
навчання перервалося
Ми теж були трохи розгублені бо не знали
як нам далі що нам далі робити І через
деякий час вже в березні наші вчителі
почали запитувати нас писати нам листи
чи буде відновлення чи зможуть вони
закінчити чи відновимо ми цей курс тоді
Ми зрозуміли що можливо потрібно зробити
аналіз потреб вчителів
принаймні
тут того не творику Да Тих вчителів з
якими ми працювали і Запитати їх чим ми
можемо допомогти з професійним розвитком
так народився новий проект який Ми
назвали дуже описовано навчання і
викладання у складні часи
ініціатива базувалася на запиті вчителів
про те як саме допомагати дітям
продовжити навчання під час війни тому
що це був тільки лютий і березень і далі
потрібно було жити
Ми з'ясували з командою що в нас є така
експертиза Британській раді поговорили з
різними країнами з колегами і дуже
оперативно адаптували ці матеріали з
експертами з Британії експертами з
Європи
порадилися з нашими вчителями адаптували
матеріали запропонували Цей курс
пропонували ми його як я вже говорила
рік тому у серпні у Польщі тому що фокус
був на тих вчителів які опинилися
біженцями там у Європі і на цей курс
також запросили вчителів з Польщі з
Румунії з Прибалтики які вже приймали
приймали наших дітей які були біженцями
в Європі дуже багато було відгуків
позитивних сказали що це те що нам
потрібно і також відгуків від вчителів з
України Вони сказали що нам це теж
потрібно тому ми
почали запрошувати наших вчителів з
України і протягом вже цього року
провели 9 таких тренінгових курсів у
Польщі багато було таких цікавих
моментів коли учасники говорили що коли
я стояв на кордоні або стояла на кордоні
12 годин я запитувала чоловік запитував
Чому ти там стоїш що ти там робиш але
коли я прийшла вже курс Я не шкодувала
про те я тепер розумію як мені
повертатися що ми далі робити в класі я
перезавантажилася
але сьогодні ми думаємо Так це була
1585 вчителів нам було дійсно важко але
ми їх запросили тренували допомагали але
цього замало якщо ми думаємо про Україну
Ми думаємо про тільки вчителів
англійської мови яких до війни було 30
36 тисяч
Тому зараз ми переглянули модель
професійного розвитку для вчителів і
сьогодні те що вже
звучало від багатьох спікерів з вересня
ми починаємо
тренувати координаторів
професійних груп професійної
майстерності для вчителів англійської
мови і будемо масштабувати цей проект
через групи професійний майстерності
маємо дуже амбітні плани хотіли би
надалі співпрацювати з інститутами і ППО
також і говорили з директорами шкіл вони
готові підтримати А ми готові передати
цю методику натренувати координаторів і
я сподіваюся що саме цей Пілот стане
потім таким прикладом який можна буде
скопіювати для вчителів інших предметів
тому що це будуть групи які будуть
працювати і один одному допомагати
Дякую за ці класні приклади Та я згодна
з аудиторією що заслуговує аплодисментів
Скажіть Ви згадували про навчання в
онлайн як багато вчителів в онлайні
Ми тренуємо правому проекті Ми тренуємо
вчителів в онлайні когортами вони
заходять на платформі тому що цей курс
модерований саме кількість загальна яка
на сьогодні на сьогоднішній день 800 вже
закінчили курс зараз
1414 серпня навчаються і до маємо таку
абітну мету до кінця березня 2024 року
натренувати 7 тисяч вчителів Дякую питаю
про онлайн тому що один з інструментів
для тих хто буде навчатися онлайн А
зараз Звичайно що освітян таких буде
більше хотів презентувати Олександр тому
дивимось на екран і Олександр включиться
і розкаже нам про інструменти Двейн Я
впевнена що багато хто в залі про нього
вже чули Олександр є контакт
добре
мало другі колеги зробити державний
стандарт у сучасний зміст навчальних
програм чи оновити освітнє середовище
хоча все це без сумніву дуже важливо Але
найголовніше це вчителя його підготовка
нових учительських методик не буде поки
ми не змінимо систему підвищення
кваліфікації
Це не мої слова ці слова належать лівій
Гриневич вона їх сказала у спільному з
мон на той час досліджені навчати і
навчатися Як і куди звертати
українського вчительства от я його зараз
показую на екрані це дуже символічний
жест тому що тоді от на початках реформи
якраз ми замислювалися над тим як
змінювати в принципі систему
професійного зростання вчительства не
так званих засадах 3D якими я вас
інтригував на початку 3D - Це де
монополізація децентралізація
доброчесність
плоди цих змін ми вже можемо бачити
незважаючи на кризи на секвестри до речі
про нові вимоги і можливості у цієї ви
електронної системи можна дізнатися
більш в онлайновому курсі який ми
зробили спільно з промітесом і державою
який вже пройшли тисячі освітян які ви
легко зможете знайти в інтернеті Наша
команда не тільки розробляла зміна до
освітньої політики але й запропонувала
конкретний інструменти це інструмент був
у дослідній експлуатації починаючи з 1
червня 21 року а вчора Дорогі колеги до
нашої 32 річниці незалежності ми
опублікували його розширену версію для
всієї країни це дуже тішить цю нашу
команду і спільноту тож зустрічайте
зараз на екрані ви бачите
національна платформу можливостей
професійного розвитку педагогічних
працівників хендвей є дуже легко знайти
за адресою
away.in.ua і краще один раз побачити ніж
багато разів почути і Мої колеги Зараз
будуть показувати вам платформу А я буду
Коротко і коментувати але почну з подяк
бо без допомоги
без фонду Відродження без підтримки
нашого профільного комітету міністерства
інших інституційних партнерів таку
вагому розробку цифрову ми б не змогли
підняти adway ми по-іншому називаємо
Дорогі колеги освітнім компанійоном на
шляху професійного розвитку це фактично
місце зустрічі тих хто навчає і тих хто
навчається у дорослому освітянському
колі і двері має дві основні задачі
перше завдання - це цифрова підтримка
для всіх сторін процесу підвищення
кваліфікації педагогічних працівників
власне освітян закладів освіти суб'єктів
підвищення кваліфікації від держави так
само і недержавних мережі центрів
професійного розвитку і можливість для
держави для українського інституту
розвитку освіти спостерігати за цим
процесом починаючи від моменту пошуку
можливо професійного зростання і
завершуючи верифікації цього процесу і
підтвердженням якості і друга важлива
задача - це власне сприяти розбудові
цього партнерського середовища розвивати
ринок підвищення кваліфікації звичайно
на засадах відповідності державної
освітній політиці і зокрема професійним
стандартом на сьогодні Дорогі колеги на
платформі понад 200 суб’єктів підвищення
кваліфікації як інститутів
післядипломної екологічної освіти так і
менедержавних гравців громадських
організацій бізнесів і власне самих
освітян пропонують майже 700 можливостей
для підвищення кваліфікації кожен третій
педагог най завершує навчання із
сертифікатом із документом і ми бачимо
що за місяці повномасштабного вторгнення
кількість користувацької аудиторії
зросла усім разів тому якщо ви ще не
маєте свій профіль на alway то саме час
його створити до дня незалежності
всеукраїнської серпневої ми поліпшили
дизайн переосмислювали користувацький
інтерфейс-платформ додали календар
можливостей удосконалену версію
виготовлення документів про підвищення
кваліфікації з'явився моніторинг облік в
один професійного зростання з графічним
представленням дуже зручним формуванням
звітів для атестації та інших потреб є
Тепер внутрішня система комунікації
соціальна авторизація через Google до 1
вересня відповідно
технічні деталі і краще ми з колегами
будемо всіх закликати реєструватися
заходити і гратися з цим чудовим
інструментом самостійно Дуже дякую Я
тоді скажу буквально останні речення що
дорогі колеги хочу зробити важливий
анонс 20 і 22 вересня будемо проводити
серію майстерег про те як використати
всі можливості і двері на повну
відповідний лист підтримки в
Міністерства вже пішов регіони і
заохочую вас реєструватися і дізнаватися
більше
Дякуємо Олександр І дякую за нагадування
від Олександра власне про дослідження і
про цитату лілії Гриневич яка була
приурочена до старту нужна про те що
будь-яка реформа ризикує залишитися на
папері без належної підтримки і з
навчання освітян і до нуш хотілося
рухатися І власне Так зветься наша
локація І я б хотіла попросити пані
Ольгу Донець розказати
про ті інструменти бо я знаю що з таких
організацій громадського сектору Ви
працюєте з ну ж дуже багато давайте про
ваші ініціативи з підтримки нуш
говоріть він стартує так вже чутно
насправді ми говорили ще про виклики Да
і як ми реагували як програма реагувала
програма демократична школа реагувала і
продовжувала підтримувати
пані Олю з перервами так чи ні Чудово
дякую тай Ми з стикнулися з тим що
побачили що після початку
повномасштабного вторгнення спільнота
освітян вона
був такий запит на спілкування Да і щоб
були такі спільні майданчики де вчителі
ділилися викликами і спільно шукали
рішення цих викликів тобто не вистачало
спілкування і ми вирішили що це треба
враховувати і плюс додавати якраз
просування в цих цінностях нової
української школи так з'явився у нас
курс шкільне життя онлайн
він про те як робити дистанційну освіту
цікавою і як для дітей і як для вчителів
і він був дуже успішним А ми мали дуже
великий попит серед вчителів Це був
фасилітований онлайн-курс шкільне життя
онлайн і більше ніж
600 вчителів пройшли цей курс І до речі
ми організовували такі курс пілотний та
Львівського і по для ваших колег і теж
мали прекрасний відгуки віримо що він
піде далі в масці до вчителів і до дітей
і
також хочемо сказати про один з таких
сильних інструментів які є зараз теж
з'являються якими дуже скоро будемо
анонсувати це фасилітований онлайн-курс
про формувальне оцінювання для вчителів
і ми дуже очікували його знаємо що серед
вчителів теж є дуже великий запит якраз
нова українська школа теж просуває
формувальне оцінювання Цей курс для
вчителів-предметників які знають вже що
таке формувальне оцінювання але вони не
знають з чого розпочати Да в них не
вистачає інструментів технік
формувального оцінювання курс буде дуже
практичним він буде теж мати учасників
учасниці будуть мати можливість зустрічі
із авторами авторками курсу дуже рада що
в залі присутні теж одна з авторокурсу і
одна з тренерок програми демократична
школа дуже рада вас бачити І
власне
всі курси фасилітовані в тому числі
формувальне оцінювання сьогодні дуже
практичними по завершенню цих курсів
вчителів вже інтегрують елементи курсів
свої навчальні програми Тобто ми не
просто говоримо да Як прекрасно знати
про формувальне оцінювання а вони
інтегрують різні елементи формувального
оцінювання вже в своїй навчальній
програмі і виходять з готовим з готової
програмою яку вони можуть одразу після
курсу втілювати в життя також хочу
сказати що з Жовтня цього року
навчального року в нас буде ще декілька
нових курсів формулювальне оцінювання
для адміністрації школи для директорів
також буде курс про командатворення і
про культуру демократів навчальних
закладах і також буде курс по
учнівському самоврядування для колег цпр
і для іпо і хочу ще зазначити до нас
дуже часто звертаються з таким
запитанням Я хочу зазначити що всі курси
програми демократична школа є
безкоштовними всі учасники учасниці
дотримують сертифікати ми маємо програму
підвищення кваліфікації і отримують
сертифікати від 25 до 40 годин в
залежності від курсів тому дуже будемо
раді вас бачити нових курсах програми
демократична школа На жаль ми маємо
можливість показати вам qr-код але
можете зайти на сайт програми
демократична
школа.org також маємо сторінку в
Фейсбуці програма демократична школа
європейський центр імені вергелента і
вже з наступного тижня всі ті курси
фасилітовані які я про які я зараз
говорила вони будуть
оголошені і дуже раді будемо вас на них
бачити Ну за матеріалами нашої дискусії
Сьогодні ми ще напишемо підбірку для
освіторія медіа обов'язково спокликання
ми на всі організації ресурси і я завжди
Так хвилююся чути про сертифікати і всі
так про це нагадують друзі Я думаю що це
само собою розуміється і все одно
українські вчителі вони йдуть навчатися
не за сер плакатами сподіваємося
розповсюджене запитання
всі хто сьогодні присутні обов'язково їх
видають Дякую за ваші класні ініціативи
для підтримки нуш власне Юрій я знаю що
від самого моменту старту реформи ви
особисто як освіторія працюємо з
підтримкою нуш розробляли не перший курс
для вчителів початкової школи ми
говоримо про рестарт які найважливіші от
зараз інструменти ініціативи для цього
рестарту про що питають вчителі Яких їх
їхні болі в контексті нуш
Я не чую Юрія так Кажіть зараз вас
звукорежу цим вже ідеально Дякую панізує
запитання найголовніше мабуть те що
об'єднує усіх нас зараз на цій панельній
дискусії
учасників це те що стане запорукою
успішного рестарту чи перезавантаження
чи будь-якого іншого слова яке ми
використаємо для цього процесу це процес
об'єднання ми з вами побачили які
можливості має кожен з провайдерів який
займається наданням освітніх послуг для
вчителів і вчителі очікують якогось
певного комплексного рішення від усіх
нас тому мабуть цей майданчик стане
початком синергії і успішного
продовження реформи зважаючи на синергію
і досвід який має громадська спілка
освіторія у
старті реформи збірна українська школа
це величезна робота з тренерською
когортою за інститутів післядипломної
педагогічної освіти Ми сподіваємося на
цю синергію і надалі і вже підготували
ті матеріали які допоможуть власне усім
галузевим координаторам координатором
нуш в
базовій середній освіті це курс про який
вже сьогодні згадував він доступний і
допоможе вам створювати різноманітні
навчальні формати у тому числі і змішані
формати де учасники зможуть попередньо
перед практичним курсом зануритися за
допомогою онлайн-курсу Також ми сьогодні
на платформі у університет підготували
до серпневої конференції посібник
путівник який вже доступний на платформі
можна його завантажити і використовувати
для для того щоб мати цілісну картину
про те що таке нуш на рівні базової
середньої освіти Ми також маємо
усі разом зараз об'єднатися з дуже
важливою темою це подолання освітніх
втрат сьогодні на панельній дискусії вже
були оприлюднені для широкого загалу
результати і ці результати На жаль
нарадують а навпаки заставляють нас все
більше
комплексніше подивитися на проблеми які
є в початковій школі які є в базовій і
яким чином їх долати як допомогти
вчителям працювати зараз в класі з
учнями з абсолютно різними потребами
освітніми з абсолютно різним рівнем
готовності до сприйняття
сприйняття інформації тому громадська
спілка аситорія разом з юнісеф
розпочинає вже в жовтні підготовку
тренерів від інститутів і
метрів
професійного розвитку які допоможе
вчителям працювати з освітніми втратами
ідентифікувати їх і мати комплексні
набір інструментів для того щоб
власне ці прогалини і втрати долати а
також це дуже глобальна тема попри те що
ми маємо досвід в навчанні під час
ковіду Але до цього часу у нас є не
закриті сліпі плями з дистанційним
навчанням і ми розуміємо що величезна
кількість закладів знищена а це означає
що вони будуть продовжувати працювати в
дистанційному форматі і це це навчання
потребує покращення для того щоб цих
втрат не було на наступний навчальний
рік ще більше ніж ми маємо зараз тому
частина цього проекту буде спрямована на
покращення дистанційного і змішаного
навчання
розробимо
спеціальний курс для вчителів і
онлайн-курс для вчителів який допоможе
уже системно і комплексно подивитися на
процес дистанційного і змішаного
навчання і я думаю що
одне з дуже важливих питань на які ми
теж маємо разом знайти спільне рішення
це яким чином буде відбуватися освітня
реінтеграція на деокупованих територіях
це власне питання яке потребує вже
нагального нагальних рішень комплексних
рішень тому теж закликає усіх нас
подумати про те яким чином ми будемо
долати цей виклик Дякую за цю тезу за
цей важливий посил для нас усіх про
разом ми про співпрацю і Якщо говорити
про співпрацю Юрій багато говорив про
середню базову школу і про переміщення
реформи нуш рестарт її там після того як
країна стабілізувалася
повномасштабну війну знаєш що пані
Оксана фунда ції Lego продовжують робити
фокус на нуш в початковій школі
Розкажіть будь ласка про це детальніше
як вчителям-початківцям за чим їм до вас
іти
ви починаєте говорити звукорежисер
увімкне
Якщо так там ідеально Все уже добре
чутно так власне за нашими спинами ми
бачимо надпис рестарт нуш Ми продовжуємо
фокус на початковій школі початковій
школі Нам вдалося вибудувати фундамент
до початку ковіду до початку
повномасштабного вторгнення і тому зараз
дуже важливо допомогти вчителям особливо
тим педагогам які повертаються до роботи
офлайн далі продовжувати реформу нуш
поглиблювати розширювати але уже з
урахуванням реалість сьогодення ми як
фундація Lego виділяємо наразі 100
мільйонів гривень для того щоб провести
навчання усіх вчителів початкової школи
протягом жовтня 23 квітня 2024 року не
тільки фінанси ми готові вкласти в цей
процес оскільки коли розпочиналася
реформа нуш для нас це так само дитя яке
ми разом з усіма
виношували і плекали і тому дуже буде
шкода якщо
вас чутно не хвилюйтеся це буде шкода
Якщо нам
нечутно це напевно вам не чутно це
можливо мені не чутно дуже буде шкода
Якщо нам не вдасться продовжити цю
реформу і її поглибити тому окрім 100
мільйонів гривень ми відповідаємо за те
щоб надати зміст для проведення цих
тренінгів Ми відповідаємо за навчання
регіональних тренерів і наразі що
відбувається механізм реалізації цього
проєкту цієї програми підвищення
кваліфікації відбувається спільно з
інститутами післядипломної освіти наразі
разом з вашими кураторами Ми обираємо
регіональних тренерів які будуть
здійснювати навчання якщо це навчання в
онлайні Бо в нас є регіони які до сих
пір і навчатимуться ще в онлайні Ми так
само проводимо другу паралель і будемо
навчати і тренерів і вчителів які
навчатимуть в онлайні але метою цього є
поглибити цінність нуш і паралельно із
навчання вчителів які вже в практиці ми
далі рухаємося розширення нашої
співпраці із саме вищої освіти фахової
передвищої освіти бо в нас будуть
приходити майбутній вчитель Який теж має
докорінно і глибоко розуміти концепцію
філософію нової української школи тому
наступний рік у нас такий плідний
глибокий широкий але все заради того щоб
оцінювати про які ми говорили ми могли
зреалізувати з нашими вчителями у нашій
країні Дякую Оксана за підтримку цього
посилу разом ми за стільки корисних
нових ініціатив за не слово мала
питання до вас не знаю наскільки вам
підтримує теж рестарт нуш і однозначно
цей запит у вчителів з'явився він болить
чи відчуваєте ви це ман і які додаткові
болі вчителів в процесі ви бачите
прохання коротко тому що вже час
закінчується але ми обов'язково хочемо
почути який семан і іппо
які болі ми відчуваємо Мені здається у
нас зараз усіх одна і та сама біль - це
те що дуже багато педагогів немає
доступу до живих заходів живого
підвищення підвищення кваліфікації тому
що
навчити педагога мовника можна онлайн
навчити педагога предметника який
наприклад там біолог або хімік Це
набагато важче тому мені здається ми
зараз займаємо ту позицію що ми
Запрошуємо усіх колег до живих заходів
до живих практикумів для того щоб мати
можливість безпосередньо щоб педагог
володів навичками і інструментими які
вже може втілювати в себе в навчанні і
от заради цього наприклад як один з
заходів зроблю таку афішу невеличку А ми
плануємо навчання
по природничим наукам це методика
викладання за підручником природничі
науки п'ятий клас ми його розпрацювали
спільно з інститутом педагогіки напад
Тобто це такий собі спільний продукт і
ще є кілька моментів які ми зараз
фокусуємося це навчання тих педагогів
які досі проживають над окупованих
територіях або там ще ведуться бойові
дії дуже часто до нас звертаються такі
педагоги з приводу того що
не просто провчити мене а виділіть нам
наприклад на наш на нашу школу або на
наш район декілька курсів приїдьте до
нас і так далі тому з осені ось вересень
жовтня Ми плануємо підтримку саме цим
регіонам в першу чергу і в першу чергу
плануємо залучати їх тому що зазвичай ми
робили Як каже
пан хобзей ми брали усіх бажаючих тому
що ми хочемо навчати усіх але з цього
року зовсім ні ми плануємо акцент
зробити на це і хочеться сказати про те
що от колеги говорили Да дуже часто
педагоги запитують про сертифікати щоб
уникнути цього питання ми зробили
взагалі по-іншому ми на будь-який наш
курс відразу публікуємо макет
сертифікату який педагог має отримати
тобто щоб зняти це питання і педагог був
спокій і в нього було лише завдання одне
провчитися гарно і отримати сертифікат
тому Я запрошую усіх на наш сайт він
звісно можливо не такий
суперфункціональний як нам показував наш
п Олександр колега Але я думаю що
будь-який педагог знайде Там відповіді
на всі питання так само як і вчитель або
директор центру професійного розвитку
або директор іппо І наостанок якщо в нас
немає часу скажу лише про те що 9
вересня Ми плануємо таке собі
ознайомлення з нашими локаціями де
безпосередньо в нас проходить підвищення
кваліфікації Тому ці місця не або ті хто
поруч живе Запрошуємо до нас 9 вересня
Слідкуйте за афішами Дякуємо за
озвучення того запиту на живе навчання я
думаю ми сьогодні його з вами навіть всі
ми відчуваємо в цій аудиторії пане Павла
в контексті нуш рестарту нового дихання
звичайно неможливо буде рухатися безіппо
ви вже казали що ви є найважливіші
провайдери ви про доступ до освіти
освітянам всієї країни в Незалежності
від місця проживання але давайте
відверто не всі ППО поки такі як ваші і
є
Ну ніхто не ідеальний власне всі
присутні от в контексті появи великої
кількості гравців громадського сектору в
контексті запиту держави як
іппо бути ефективнішим які проблеми в
яких на сьогодні об'єднують і як отой
слоган разом який запропонував Юрій як
можна бути корисними в тому процесі для
іппо що може зробити держава і
громадський сектор
Дякую я тезував перше дякую Оксана
дійсно треба працювати щоб в початковій
школі там ще купа роботи тобто якщо 30%
класів працює за концепцією нуш це це
великий успіх друге
перехід в п'ятий клас нуш який був він
був дуже тяжкий в силу певних обставин
не буде говорити І що є прикро що ми
зауважили у Львівській області що
вчителі-предметники базової освіти
почали негативно впливати на вчителів
початкової школи Тобто там де не навпаки
що ми розраховували що ну це Київ
початкові змінить нам вчителів
там базової освіти вони будуть знати
сталося Навпаки це з питання оцінювання
зокрема тому дуже важливо те що ми
робимо зараз я прийду це питання
інститут що ми працюємо з командами
директор заступник директора і базові
вчителі базових предметів але якщо
директор заступник директора не буде
підтри який реалізовувати шанси нашої
твердити нуш є дуже дуже низькі
насправді бо початківець він один в
класі І цього достатньо Коли ти маєш
гроно вчителів тобі повинна бути команда
що йде тяжко вчителям Вони ж працювали
за підручниками ніхто не працював за
стандартом за таким складним стандартом
який прописує результати як досягає
робити ми все говоримо Ми вчимо освітніх
програм ми вчимо діяльність знову
підходу Про що ви говорили і чи ми
займаєтесь і найскладніше це є питання
оцінювання тобто цього формувального
оцінювання тої яке воно має бути тому
для того якщо ми хочемо мати результати
то безумовно ми завжди її відкриті і Я
погоджуюсь Юрій вчителька нам не треба
блабла дайте нам інструменти якими
будемо мати чому підручник не дає
діагностичних матеріалів немає як
реалізовувати стандарт тих посібників
немає є тільки стандарт і є стара тради
підручників не було взяло старі
підручники не жив Я думаю що за старими
підручниками попередніх років в нас буде
нова українська школа тому колеги ми є
відкриті ми їх Готуємо ми вам дуже
вдячні Я ще починалось подяки і завершую
подякою в своїх курсах які ми робимо ми
маємо блок е-е блок вчителів практиків е
тому що вони всі наші практики міг
заступник який є відомий Сергій позюк
який зараз в силу певних обставин іде
працювати в школу каже слухай те що ми
вчили робили Я пішов вчителем Дивіться
воно так воно так не йде Тобто це дуже
важливо коли це роблять ті люди які ну
які ти йдеш викладати ти робиш І тоді ти
колегам розказуєш як воно має бути оцей
досвід уже
А на практиці і ти це зробив Тоді це
буде ефект Ну я вірю в те що ми це
зробимо і дякую вам
Дякуємо друзі аплодисменти зробимо
однозначно завершуємо нашу панель хочу і
завершити словами Генрі Форда який казав
коли людина припиняє навчатися вона
старі в Незалежності від того чи це в 20
чи в 60 років відбулося послухавши
сьогодні побачивши всю ту палітру Я
думаю українські вчителі будуть вічно
молодими безсмертними і будемо лупатися
скалу Всім дякую гарного продовження дня
До побачення пані олені тоді до зв'язку
бачення
м часом і Подивимося може нам варто Ще
когось запросити до
приїхали до вечора розумієш що всі
втомилися але нас дуже з вами сьогодні
важлива тема яку необхідно проговорити
дуже швидко нагадаю два важливих моменти
перший те що ми у разі повітряної
тривоги ви пам'ятаєте Ми повинні перейти
з вами покриття на своїх бейджиках
учасники побачать найближче вихід де ви
можете за вказівниками дістатися укриття
другий ще один важливий момент те що ми
просимо вас дуже не публікувати
фотографію Відео і не робити позначки
геолокації з міркування безпеки
тепер важливе сказати що сьогодні наша
панель присвячена реформі новий
Кримській школі ми сьогодні так багато
про це говорили але ми розуміємо що
одним з найважливіших напевно елементів
впроваджень впровадження нової
української школи Звичайно є пілотні
заклади освіти з яких Все починалось
починалося все з 2017 року коли у нас
була одна сотня
шкіл готов інноваторів які були готові
до змін які готові були ризикувати
впроваджувати якісні підходи в освіті
які були готові надавати зворотний
зв'язок Міністерства для того щоб воно
могло втручатися позитивно втрачатися
робити зміни такі які покращать освіту
Звичайно що ця цифра змінювалась у нас
їх було сотня спочатку потім трошки
більше трошки менше станом на зараз у
нас 145 шкіл які постійно комунікують з
міністерством які надають зворотний
зв'язок без яких звичайно ми би не могли
однозначно пробувати впроваджувати нову
українську школу Сьогодні ми будемо з
вами говорити про такі важливі моменти
як забезпечення пілоту або пілоту нас
приходить сьомий клас який є проблеми
які є виклики які є напрацюванні
результати пілоту ми власне і почнемо з
наших представників пілотних шкіл які
сьогодні в нас є це в нас є сьогодні
троє це
це у нас Ірина Дубас директор ліцею №3
міста Нова Каховка херсонського області
це пані Лариса слюсарева яка є
заступницею директора навчально-виховної
роботи лиманського ліцею старобільської
міської ради Луганської області і з нами
сьогодні є пані Олена вертипорах вона є
директоркою золотоніської
спеціалізованої школи №2 Черкаської
області сьогодні ми поговоримо Вітаю
колег там сьогодні ми поговоримо які ж є
результати пілоту Чи ви бачите
відмінності в навчальних результатівнях
ваших учнів які були і як ви
впроваджували Пілот В умовах воєнного
стану в умовах війни будь ласка колеги
давайте пані Ірино почнемо
вітаю щиро Шановні колеги дуже радію за
тих хто розпочне навчання офлайн і також
радію що розпочнемо навчання онлайн тому
що ми знаємо що багато освітніх закладів
не розпочали В тому році можливо в цьому
році запустяться можливо теж не
розпочнуть
але все ж таки я знову її Каховки третій
ліцей ми впроваджуємо державний стандарт
з першого класу і мій єдиного разу не
зійшли із шляху все що потрібно всі які
плани у нас були ми всі плани виконували
незважаючи на те що 24 лютого Нова
Каховка була окупована зараз тимчасово
окупована і
в 22-му році Нам вдалося закінчити
навчальний рік Хоча і в кінці квітня
місяця з учнями а з
1-8 десятих класів А 9-11 ми ще якось
закінчували у травні та червні місяці
тим не менше документи учні всі отримали
і Нам вдалося розпочати новий навчальний
рік
минулий незважаючи на те що Нова Каховка
в окупації Ми розпочали моїй школі було
625 учнів на перше вересня
стало було 670 на 1 вересня 22 стало
611 тобто втратила я небагато через те
що дуже багато
біженців які переїхали з Нової Каховки
до підконтрольної України і багато
виїхали з-за кордон на сьогоднішній день
у мене 615 учнів Із них 249 в окупації
220 за кордоном і тільки 100 з лишнім
тільки на підконтрольній тут свої нюанси
всякі все залежить від батьків ми всі
знаємо що за кордоном виплачують
непогано допомогу батьки можуть находити
підробіток тому тут від цього всього
залежить
зрозуміло що коли почалося Вторгнення в
лютому місяці Ми всі були в паніці тому
що ви розумієте що ми не знаємо хто з
нами поруч адже колаборантів виявилося є
із друзів із колег і так далі І
я буду говорити про себе про
третій ліцей міста Нова Каховка
Херсонської області
я все ж таки взяла себе в руки тому що
розуміла що якщо не буду з'являтися в
онлайні не будуть спілкуватися з
батьками з учнями з вчителями я можу
втратити навчальний заклад Таким чином
через всю паніку яка там була я зуміла
все ж таки
зробити так що кругом в мене було коло
батьків сильних морально коло вчителів
тому що ви розумієте що побігли всі в
лютому хто куди в березні Тим паче і ми
чекали все ж таки що Нову Каховку
звільняють і чекаємо сьогодні віримо в
ЗСУ що її звільняють Але тих решестів
ніяк неможливо вибити з Нової Каховки
Тим
паче зробили все можливе щоб закінчити
навчальний рік
і так сталося що рашисти з автоматами
прийшли до мене в освітній заклад і
вигнали нас з освітнього закладу в
серпні місяці забрали ключі Ну і так
сталося що мене посадили в на підвал
тільки тому що я була займалася
експериментальною діяльністю вони чітко
розуміли що
директори шкіл які займаються
експериментальною діяльністю Вони є
прикладом для всіх інших ну при всьому
тому що
я працюю директором майже 20 років і
колеги в Новій Каховці
радяться зі мною прислухаються до мене
ми разом спілкуємося разом Приймаємо
рішення ну Таким чином рашисти Навіть
нерешести наші колаборанти які стали у
руля в Новій Каховці посадили мене на
підвал подумати декілька днів і прийняти
рішення написати заяву про співпрацю
зрозуміло я перед собою нічого не бачила
крім як йти до кінця і якось на той час
мені було все рівно ці 5 діб які я
перебувала на підвалі
цей Буряти нас виховували і все ж таки
ми не випустили і дали мені два дні
подумати і написати заяву але чоловік
мене Швидко переправив на підконтрольну
територію і я не переставала
продовжувати адже це було мене випустили
24 серпня на День незалежності ФСБ мені
подарунок зробили такий привітали І я
так сказать звідти виїхала і
розпочала далі працювати
духом не впала тому що розуміли якщо
впаду духом Я що тоді буде бачу вчителі
почали звільнятися вчителі почали
влаштовуватися на
підконтрольній території України у школи
які працювали офлайн по селах вчителі за
кордоном почали влаштовуватися на якісь
заводи фабрики почали прибирати в
готелях і хочу що ми колективи втрачаємо
колектив втрачаємо ну це не тільки ми не
проблема була я спілкуюся з багатьма
колегами Я знаю що це у багатьох були
проблеми все ж таки ми згрупувалися і
відкриваємо наш третій ліцей і
продовжуємо свою експериментальну
діяльність мої шості класи ні єдиного
заходу не пропустили ні єдиного
моніторингу показали гарні результати
всі заступник директора з
експериментальної діяльності теж
працювала і міська рада не припиняла
доплачувати на півставки на заступника
директора я завдячую що міська Влада вже
який рік іде нам на зустріч і півставки
виділили все ж таки на експериментальну
діяльність хотілося б щоб це було на
рівні держави не тільки на рівні
місцевих рад
далі хочу сказати про те що ми прийшли
всі етапи єдина була проблема до нас
прибували діти в 6 клас зовсім чужі з
інших територій які окуповані і вони не
були
привчені навчені Тому що наші діти уже
вміли з початкової школи з першого класу
в цьому була у нас складність і для
вчителів теж тому наші Вчителі були
змушені в шостому класі
допрацьовувати з учнями інших районів
Херсонської області Запорізької області
які до нас прибули
допрацьовувати з учнями матеріал тому що
шостий класи Вони ж прогресивніші ті що
в експерименті аніж звичайні тому в
цьому труднощі що навантаження було на
вчителів зрозуміло і на адміністрацію
тобто ось такий виклик величезний далі
був виклик величезний в тому що кадри
зрозуміло що кадри в Польщі готувалися
українські школи і саме які працювали на
в експерименті адже вони теж прогресивні
Вони ж їх навчили за ці 6 років і я їх
втрачаю тільки тому що вони були під
ковані своїми знаннями Пішли працювати в
польській школі Так для українських
дітей там є українські школи по типу
материнка ви можливо чули такі школи і
тут я нічого не могла зробити тому що
наша зарплата копійчана і я не могла
нічого зробити мені треба було прийняти
нових вчителів далі прийняла я нових
вчителів на 1 вересня
22-го року мені треба було їх вчити і
дуже чітко багато вчити дякуючи наша
академія неперервної освіти все ж таки
на початку вересня і в серпні трішечки
підготували наших вчителів нових
вчителів але все ж таки ви розумієте що
вчителі перший рік починають працювати в
експерименті І коли вони вже з п'ятого
класу працюють це теж Велика різниця тут
повинні бути
додаткові мето Німеччині наставники в
закладі які могли б працювати але теж
безкоштовно працювали все ж таки Нам
вдалося це шостий клас ми прийшли вдало
але все ж таки я сказала вже більше 200
дітей знаходяться в окупації нам треба
їх вчити і зараз і всьому класі Діти теж
знаходяться в окупації нам треба вчити
при цьому тому що з Нової Каховки
попереджали в різних маленьких селах
живуть щоб рашисти не ходили не
примушували їх навчатися в своїх школах
хоча в Новій Каховці не відкрилася ні
єдина школа Але в цьому році вони
планують відкрити онлайн одну школу і
працювати І вони обшукують будинки
квартири сусіди якісь дають там бабусі і
дідусі розказують де Діти що роблять
чому батьки не Здають і діти бояться
батьки бояться є у нас діти які зна ця в
Криму
вимушено чи в Генічеському районі але
вони все ж таки вчаться паралельно
ходять до тих шкіл які там
повідкривалися і паралельно вчаться в
нас щоб не втрачати українського світу
директор дуже складно в цьому випадку
але директор повинен все зробити щоб
дитина сім'я цієї цього учня чи учениці
відчували що вони не кинуті що вони
увагу їм приділяють навчання
продовжуються і все ж таки поселити
надію в душах що ми їх не кинемо що вони
продовжують ми далі навчатися хотілося б
дуже хотілося щоб звільнили швидше нашу
територію України Взагалі І не робили з
нами того що роблять зараз саме в Новій
Каховці всі виклики які постали перед
саме нашим ліцеєм ми всі подолали і
подолаємо тому що третій ліце зокрема
Нова Каховка 0 колаборантів я цим
пишаюся І хочу сказати про те що якби я
отам на підвалі здалася то можливо
півколективу і було колаборантів як де є
Ви читаєте це і так далі але все ж таки
дириктор це така особистість яка повинна
показувати свою роль в педагогічному
колективі взагалі в своєму закладі і
показувати Куди прямувати далі Коли
батьки діти бачать що директор крокує
впевнено не пускає сльози він може
наодинці пустить сльози соплі і так далі
але перед колективом пере дітьми треба
бути впевненими і продовжувати свою
справу не можна розділяти ні людей Ні
справу дякую
Я думаю що ви заслужили просто на
неймовірні Оплески тому що це настільки
емоційна розповідь наскільки складно це
було чути Дякуємо що знайшли сміливість
розказати нам це все і сила будь ласка
колеги продовжуєте беріть мікрофон
Мої вітання Вам Шановні колеги
всі сказані слова і Пані Оленою і Пані
директоркою Каховського ліцею вони
перегукуються з луганщиною Я сьогодні
представляю тут не тільки свій рідний
ліцей А всі чотири заклади Луганщини які
в 17-му році
теж не побоялися взяти на свої тендітні
плечі можна говорити
ось такий інноваційний
всеукраїнський проєкт як
апробація державного стандарту
початкової загальної середньої освіти
на сьогоднішній день на сьогоднішній
день
важко Дуже говорити що відбувається але
все ж таки я Буду намагатися до вас
коротко але донести що що твориться в
наших
освітніх закладах якщо в 17-му році було
4 експериментальних заклади освіти то на
[музика]
2022 і вже 23-й тобто в минулому
навчальному році нас залишилося три і як
сказала пані директор велика вам шана і
повага Саме через те що у свадівському
ліцеї сама директор пішла на співпрацю
стала колаборанткою ми втратили на
Луганщині цей експериментальний освітній
заклад і залишилося нас три тобто
втрачаємо мережу закладів освіти в
Луганській області щодо всеукраїнської
експерименту
розроблення та впровадження стандартів
освіти
після закладів освіти Ми почали втрачати
кадровий потенціал це зрозуміло так що
сталося В нашому лиманському ліцеї
старобільської територіальної громади
Луганської області в нас сталося те що я
заступник і вчитель початкових класів
якщо відверто ми домовилися з директором
що ми не йдемо на співпрацю і з нами
весь колектив 30 травня ще була на
роботі я приймала журнали я приймала всі
звідти Я всі документи відправляла в
архів ми видали дітям
свідоцтва про повну базову середню
освіту видали дев'ятий класникам
видали свідоцтва досягнень новій
українській школі ми їх так називаємо
наше мишенятам які вдало Потім були
колаборантами спалені разом із особовими
справами і коли батьки приходили до
ліцею хотіли забрати документи
виїжджаючи із тимчасово окупованої
території то наші колеги які також були
в експерименті відповідали а особових
справ немає а батьки свідоцтво досягнень
А це ж не документ
це говорила вчителька яка
експериментувала з першого по четвертий
клас на жаль це реалії
що було ти і зараз є на сьогоднішній
день старобільщина залишається тимчасово
окупованою
контингент учителів він роз'їхався по
Європі
по Україні і лише сім я не знаю як їх
назвати пішли на співпрацю одна стала
директоркою інша заступником директора і
так по
вертикалі напевно
так доля розпорядилася
щось в мене якісь технічні
чутно
Ні не чутно А це в мене тут з вухом
дякую
Ну і після цих всіх кадрових втрат і ви
знаєте не шкода тих хто пішов на
співпрацю складає правильно сказала пані
директор шкода тих людей які пішли в
готелі
прибиральницями які пішли в ресторани
посудомийницями і так далі І так далі
оцих людей шкода тому що їх навчали вони
були професіоналами своєї справи І вони
дійсно несли на плечах на своїх реформу
нової української школи і несли достойно
і ми завжди цим пишалися такими людьми
такими вчителями на Луганщині
відповідно новий навчальний рік
ми всі розкидані де завгодно діти батьки
вчителі і тут прийшла на допомогу
педагогіка партнерства одна із складових
якісної освіти і формули нової
української школи Ми почали збирати у ту
інформацію по крупиночках де хто коли на
яких умовах перебуває і ми зуміли на 1
вересня
відкрити дистанційно наш ліцей в якому
було їй богу пишаюся цією цифрою 650
здобувачів освіти перших 11-х класів і з
нашого колективу рідного так би мовити
колективу залишалося 13 педагогів і 17
ми додали сумісників і з нашої
територіальної громади Але знову ж таки
пішло на спад ми мали два пілотні класи
правильно колеги мене підтримають але
вже шостий класи в нас залишився один
пілотний клас Він багато чисельний був
37 учнів і ви розумієте що наших дітей
саме нашого ліцею там було відсотків 70
а Звичайно десь 30% ми брали всіх дітей
Ми брали кримчан і вони пишалися тим що
вони можуть здобувати українську освіту
Ми брали всіх хто виїхав за кордон Хто б
в якій ситуації до всіх був застосований
і тільки індивідуальний підхід і батьки
за це по сьогодні пишуть листи і вони
дуже і дуже вдячні нас знову на 1
вересня в нас немає таких дітей які
вибували розумієте різні ситуації Так
багато пишуть батьків ми хочемо очно
денно спробувати нема питань будь ласка
хай все складається в вашій долі Але ж
вони при одній умові якщо не так
візьмете нас назад та обов'язково
візьмемо Ну і
ось при такому скороченні я хочу
сказати
буквально ще декілька слів про Я не те
що порівняти ми не порівнюємо нові
українські школі ні Результати освітньої
діяльності ні результати
навчальної діяльності наших здобувачів
освіти наших мишенят але я хочу сказати
що наскільки ми в п'ятому класі як
виявляється Тепер уже довільний після
війни були щасливі нам кожного дня до
нашого ліцею привозили науково-методичну
літературу з якими видавництвом ми
тільки не співпрацювали Я не хочу зараз
перераховувати ви їх всі знаєте Але у
кожного вчителя
кожної освітньої галузі за навчальним
планом нової української школи базового
стандарту був величезний вибір вони йшли
Вони тільки пишалися вони розбігалися
якого автора модельної програми
навчальний посібник обрати до
інтегрованого курсу літератур чи до
інтегрованого курсу природничі науки чи
до здоров'я безпека та добробут чимось
мистецької освітньої галузі тобто до
мистецької освітньої галузі
на сьогодні в мене побажання якщо воно
має здійснитися то хай воно здійсниться
ми ми маємо в електронному вигляді всі
підручники всі навчальні посібники всі
методичні рекомендації але хоча б для
вчителя хоча б для вчителя і для тих
дітей які перебувають на підконтрольній
території України і для тих батьків які
згодні оплатити нову українську ой Нову
Пошту ми знаємо що в Польщі відкрилися
відділення в і в інших європейських
країнах щоб можна було надіслати
друковані підручники тому що все-таки
хоч Ми закінчили перший цикл базової
середньої освіти Ми з 1 вересня йдемо в
сьомий А клас в експериментальний але
друкований підручник він потрібен поруч
чи паралельно із електронним Ну і
насамкінець я не можу зараз це все
розповісти але я думаю що мої думки
перекликаються І саме головне мріє
звичайно
важкі часи на Україні але я точно вірю
що на Україні буде все гаразд дякую
дуже вам дякую пані Лариса тому що попри
такій складній умови ви продовжували
пілотувати продовжила пробивати ми
бачимо емоції на вашому обличчя Щиро
дякуємо що ми поділилися сьогодні з нами
відкрилася дякую пані Олена вам слово
вітаю Ви знаєте прослухавши попередніх
своїх колег я можу сказати що мій
навчальний заклад це золотоніська
спеціалізована школа №2 інформаційних
технологій в Черкаській області
Можливо так скажу що ми
ми
мало ми щасливі люди Ми щасливі люди
тому що
жоден вчитель початку війни не залишив
навчальний заклад можу сказати що з
цього 35 осіб дітей які з батьками
виїхали за кордон але
внутрішньо переміщених осіб із починаючи
із початку війни в школі навчається 70
осіб ми приймаємо ми приймаємо цих дітей
Ми працюємо з ними Працюємо з батьками
наш психолог можна сказати що працює на
3,5 ставки а не на 0,5 яку вона зараз
має
вчителі класні керівники це
подушки до яких приходять діти яким діти
можуть писати після 21 години а навіть
після 24 години І передавати свої страхи
які вони відчувають
Ми теж сьогодні дуже таке питання стояло
як працює школа
під час війни Да я приготувала цей
виступ приготувала презентацію якщо
можна її включити просто щоб вона йшла
і ви бачили
я буду просто перелистувати не
приєднуватись до цього да Коли ми почали
працювати в новій українській школі хочу
сказати 17-й рік я за дуже багато
говорила це
гнушівський клас У мене був через стінку
від мого кабінету і вересень жовтень
місяць у мене була така бігова дорожка
думаю Боже де ж моя Ірина Михайлівна Чи
можу вона їх залишила що ж вона робиться
ж першокласники прибігає Вони працюють і
ви знаєте з 2 місяці Я бігала а потім
уже змирилася тому що да Я в школі
працюю Я директор школи на той час яка
вже 17 років пропрацювала Да я прийшла
можна сказати там із отих перших часів і
з часів застою і мені це було Теж нове
але коли ми вже побачили своїх дітей у
5-6 класі
Ми побачили що це зовсім інші діти це не
ті діти які були це зовсім не ті Я
завжди говорила шано колеги це діти не
ми це діти не ті які навчаються у 5-му і
по перед класу
дуже рада що колектив не залишив не
залишився не розрахувалися навчалися і
хто був на попередній сесії на нашій тут
на нашій локації Я просто бачила усіх
тих спікерів усіх тих керівників курсів
безмежну усіх кожен знаю так сиджу і
поіменно думаю на цих курсах навчалася
так колега там проходило так колега
освіторія Lego фундайшин демократична
школа просто ми хватали все що можна
було хватать і оцей як би мені хотіли
якщо тут серед нас є ще директори я
думаю що ви знаєте що коли була ще стара
школа ми всі боялися методи в
діяльністьного підходу згадайте будь
ласка якщо треба було дати якийсь
відкритий урок і
ми ж як і заучу вчити як і директор каже
покажи групову форму роботу вчитель Що
робив
любима путями обходив
говорив що ні я не буду А зараз без цієї
групової роботи можна сказати жоден урок
в 5-6 класі не проходить
я буду вам сказати так що Я дуже щаслива
людина послухавши своїх спікерів і
по тому що я маю збережений колектив і
вчительський і учнів і батьків
і хочу задати таке вам риторичне питання
Як ви думаєте з чого починається нова
українська школа в моїй школі Да дійсно
ви бачите чашку кави Вона починається з
чашки кави або чаю
подивившись на все дуже багато проводила
нова українська школа всіх методів як
працювати з дітьми як зберегти дітей як
попрацювати з цими дітьми як щоб не рани
цих дітей а я так приходжу на роботу і
бачу своїх вчителів які ідуть які в яких
чоловіки пішли воювати
які На жаль
зустрічали зустріли своїх синів і
чоловіків
200 це теж дуже важко повірте мені будь
ласка і в минулому році я поставила собі
таку ціль зібрати кошти в спонсорів і
купити для своїх вчителів
стаціонарну кавову машину ви бачили їхні
очі коли на Святого Миколая
18-го привезла дуже пізно встановила
коли вони зайшли в школу в учительської
побачили каву машину про яку вони мріяли
я вам Чесно хочу сказати вони плакали і
хочу сказати отой гомір з ранку Коли я
заходжу і запах кави коли вони зранку
зовсім інший відрізняється запах кави
коли вони вже п'ють після роботи
тому що ми працюємо дуже багато працюємо
і там в травні місяці де не може навіть
раніше в квітні Коли нам підкинули наші
любимі моніторинг який ми про який Ми не
працювали А коли ви зайдете на сторінку
нашої нашого навчального закладу
ви можете найти у
Фейсбуці золотоніська спеціалізована
школа номер два інформаційних технологій
Потім ви можете ви потім перейдете на
сайт ви побачите що ми живемо таким
життям дуже активним я бачу вчителів які
йдуть по хлюпавши носа на роботу думаю
вже й кава не допомагає і в цьому році
хочу подякувати Богу хочу подякувати
всім спонсорам хочу подякувати я
назбирала 150 тисяч про це колектив
навіть не знав і
на початку серпня місяця ми всі виїхали
на три дні в Карпати мова була залишити
гаджети
дозволялося користуватися увечері з
восьмої до 9 години щоб Зателефонувати
додому і спитати Як справи гаджет
працював лише як то фотоапарат повірте
мені будь ласка що це найкраще що основа
нової української школи це вчителі
Я дуже щаслива людина на світі тому що я
маю Прекрасну доньку я Мама і я маю свій
прекрасний чудовий колектив який я люблю
без якого я не можу жити і якщо я тут
колеги бережіть цих людей тому що за
ними дійсно всі реформи
дякую вам дуже от одразу вас видно було
нушевський підходи наскільки у вас була
презентація але ви гнучко підійшли до
презентації ви вирішили розказувати
по-своєму у вас була своя форма роботи з
аудиторією тому Дякую от ви згадали про
моніторинг це цікаве питання тому що у
нас в межах дослідження освітніх прав
втрат про які сьогодні багато говорили
наприкінці навчального року цього року
державна служба якості освіти разом із
проектом sorcher за участю команди
підтримки реформ Міністерства освіти
науки провели оцінювання навчальних
досягнень шестикласників в тому числі
пілотних шкіл коротко прошу розказати
про це про успішність пілотних класів
Про те що можна ще покращувати взагалі
про результати окреслити проектного
менеджера команди підтримки реформ
Міністерства освіти і науки України
Василя Терещенка будь ласка
Дякую Олено найстрашніше слово яке
прозвучало від Олени - це коротко бо про
результати наші як пілотники можна
говорити довго
і аналізувати і думати де вдається нам
щось робити де не вдається але спробую в
межах тих 7 хвилин насправді які мені
відведені спробувати головні тези
висловити
я почну з того що подякую вам усім бо як
от сказала колега що наш моніторинг і
так само ми не тільки з моніторинним
заходимо регулярно піоні школи ми
заходимо запитуваннями різноманітними бо
вони передбачені врешті наказами які
регулюють інноваційний проєкт і одне з
головних правил будь-яких експерименту
це отримання даних які допомагають
зрозуміти де є точки напруження є де
точки є позитивного розвитку і тому вже
Вибачайте що ви вас мучимо скажімо я зі
свого боку інститут освітньої аналітики
який після мене буде розказувати свою
історію але ці дані ну критично важливі
Я розумію що найчастіше ми в межах
опитування які проводимо отримуємо
інформацію зворотний зв'язок який
говорить що пілотним шкалам І це
потрібно і це і це є скажімо зрушення
позитивні там І це дуже важлива
інформація Звісно що не можна можна
зв'язати ці проблеми знаєте махнувши
чарівною паличкою і ви це Самі знаєте
але я завжди про пілотні школи кажу для
себе з колегами коли спілкуємося це люди
все одно які розуміли на які ризики
йдуть і усвідомлюючи це вони все одно
пішли на це А це уже багато чого значить
і ми сподіваємося що саме знаєте оця як
є Прекрасне слово стресостійкість так і
оце розділ я все от опірність скажімо
негативним якимось чинникам це те що в
експерименті так само дуже важливо
побачити і слава було витримуєте Якщо
говорити про дослідження що вже
проведені в контексті освітніх втрат то
цих досліджень на сьогодні є кілька і
зокрема по початковій школі ми маємо
чисті дані
можливо якісь школи із ваших брали
зовнішньої загальнодержавної зовнішні
моніторинг якості початкової освіти ці
дані відомі і в 24-му році ще одне
дослідження буде І ми побачимо яка
динаміка скажімо в якості освіти нашої
але
говорячи про всі ці результати
висновки у нас одні поки що на жаль Коли
почався експеримент нова українська
школа точніше не експеримент а скажімо
ми як експериментатори почали його але
потім Це впроваджується в загальну
практику Ми не маємо достатніх даних для
того щоб говорити про ефективність і не
тому що ми не збираємо і не намагаємося
зрозуміти що відбувається а тому що
спочатку ковід на якомусь етапі
втрутився потім війна і в результаті ми
маємо певні дані однак їх інтерпретація
має бути надзвичайно Ну скажімо так
виваженою виваженою і коли ми підійдемо
до основної теми в межах семи хвилин які
мені відведені
а саме про результати моніторингу то це
прекрасно що державна служба якості
освіти досить швидко оперативно
запропонувала інструмент з разом із
проєктом surge і
метод дослідження і Звісно що пілотні
класи мали Навіть якби цього не було ми
мали перевірити подивитися на себе збоку
і ми отримали дані і зараз деякі з них
ми переглянемо по-перше
перші і основні дані про які я маю
сказати це те що пілотні школи
надзвичайно адаптивні отут черговий
комплімент ваш бік крім того що
вистресостійкий вищий адаптивні тому що
ми зайшли в моніторинг пізніше ніж
державна служба якості почала це робити
І я був подивований насправді бо ви
буквально там за тиждень-два ми вже
наздогнали державну службу і йшли нога в
ногу як то кажуть щоб провести
опитування і відповідно тестування в
установленні терміни звісно не всі школи
змогли і зараз ви на екрані бачити що
взагалі-то у нас за наказом 167 пілотних
шкіл на якомусь етапі декілька шкіл від
е-е
відійшли від пілоту з об'єктивних причин
інші відійшли пізніше однак на етапі
коли ми провели перше опитування скільки
шкіл хоть можуть взяти участь в цьому
моніторингу 140 погодилися але в
результаті ми маємо дані 134 шкіл
пілотних де ми провели опитування і
тестування і Як бачите цифра учнівства
яке взяло участь в моніторингу
Прекрасна але Зверніть увагу що ці
3297 учнів учениці які брали участь в
моніторингу вони фактично
представляють у нас
[музика]
644 учні які навчаються щонайменше
навчається в пілотних класах Ну от нижня
цифра жовта бачите 12,64 - це Загалом у
пілотних 140 школах Правильно а 644 це
саме пілотні учні тобто пілотники у нас
наших школах наполовину і це врешті щось
говорить про наші результати говорити Ми
щось про наші результати Якщо говорити
про інструмент то ви його прекрасно
знаєте математика українська мова
критичні абсолютно предмети для того щоб
розуміти щось про наших дітей
основні висновки так про них скажу за
браком часу що якщо хтось був присутній
на презентації якудер робила державна
служба якості освіти то нам як
пілотникам треба буде і звіт загальний
прочитати по Державній Службі якості
освіти і потім подивитися наш звіт ці
звідти з'являться
плюс-мінус в один час і ви подивитеся що
на ці дані і уважно почитаєте є дуже
багато подібного А є але є деякі нюанси
пов'язані саме з півотними школами і про
того про те я буду наголошувати у звіті
з колегами з однак кожного разу коли ви
будете читати ці звіти ви маєте на увазі
що прямого порівняння пілотних шкіл і не
пілотних шкіл категорично не можна
робити бо не пілотні школи це Село і
місто це всі регіони при цьому
репрезентативна вибірка коли ж ми
говоримо про наші наші дослідження у нас
пілотні школи - це ну це
школа-експериментальні які погодилися і
які готові були йти на всі ці ризики і
працювати в новій українській школі і
тому наші дані
очікувано від наших даних ви як вчителі
як директори керівники ви хотіли бачити
що ми вже летимо в космосі на чарівних 2
хвилини добре на чарівному
на чарівній кареті але ні діти пілотних
класів навчаються в тих самих
драматичних умовах яких навчається і не
пілотні школи так само дистанційно так
само в різних умовах і тому в деяких
місцях наші діти сильніші
подивитеся це ви побачите за тим як
окремі Ну тут вам треба задіяти своїх
буде вчителів української мови
літератури і математики відповідно щоб
вони просто дивилися завдання наприклад
на рівняння нерівності дивимося не
пілотна школа апілотна школа десь якийсь
маленький різничка буде ускладності у
складність це відсоток учнів які
виконали це завдання це вам допомагатиме
зрозуміти що скажімо десь ви як пілотна
школа про попрацювали Краще десь гірше
але загальна ситуація така з якістю
наших
з досягненнями наших учнів що динаміка
доволі подібна тобто розподіли і так
далі проблеми в непілотних школах ті
самі що на жаль і у нас спостерігається
бо якщо учні з української мови
пунктуацію на кінець шостого класу
слабенько морфологію слабенько А орфепів
так взагалі ніби її ніколи не було в
пілотних школах врешті так само як і не
пілотник то над цим треба буде працювати
і противих звіті прочитаєте коли
дивитися на розподіл отут То методологія
у нас застосована Та яка була в
Державній Службі якості освіти
застосована Як бачите 66 відсотків
середнього рівня досягли однак
що таке 66%. це насправді діти які
змогли набрати половину балів у
тестовому інструменті однак говорити що
це ну як вони мають базу Отак треба
говорити але я б сказав що нам треба
працювати так щоб більша частина їх
перемістилася все-таки на достатньо або
на високий рівень а над цим треба буде
попрацювати так само ми можемо говорити
і про українську мову Зверніть увагу що
тут так само на середньому рівні
67% учнів на достатньому 32 а початкової
високого небагато і тут різничка
насправді з
непілотною вибіркою помітна бо в них
високого рівня Трішки більше і низького
Трішки більше А у нас там майже нікого
нема Це означає що оце важливий висновок
один з що наші діти в пілотних класах
відносно рівномірно вибірка тобто якщо
знають то знають
А якщо вже не знають так дружно не
знають І власне коли ми будемо працювати
з надовгодження освітніх втрат ми маємо
дивитися на ті
показники що маємо у звіті і намагатися
виправляти і потім Ось на останніх
свайдах звернув вашу увагу зверніть
увагу що у нас працює результати наших
учнів пілотних школах певною мірою
пов'язані зверну вашу увагу пов'язані а
не залежать пов'язані це означає що це
вплив спостерігається Але який це вплив
і завдяки чому не зрозуміло один з
показників наприклад такий що діти які
навчаються дистанційно показали кращі
результати І тут відразу Всі скажуть це
чудово це прекрасно але що таке дитина
яка вчиться дистанційно Частина цих
дітей вчиться за кордоном де У них є
доступ де У них є забезпечення мабуть
Частина цих дітей вчиться з підтримкою
репетиторів батьків і так далі і тому
говорити що дистанційна освіта це
Панацея і очне навчання поступово зійде
нанівець ні так не доводиться тому коли
ви будете працювати з даними звіту
уважненько читайте і розумійте є зв'язок
Але чи це каузальний причинована слідкує
зв'язок про це ми не робимо висновків
тут потрібні глибші дослідження
одне що можу точно сказати на наступному
слайді завершувати буду Пані Олено це те
що підтримка з боку вчителя
зв'язок є і я впевнений що цей зв'язок
каузальний там де діти говорили що їм
подобається точніше діти говорили так що
українська їм подобається що вони
люблять читати і так далі І
отримували від вчителя зворотний зв'язок
у вигляді нормальної постановки завдань
нормального фідбеку щодо їхніх
результатів ті діти показували кращий
результат щойно дід дитина йшла на урок
і відчувала страх невпевненість
і одне з питань було От Краще б цього
предмета не було щойно відразу результат
знижувався А якщо дитина говорить що
вона відчуває страх перед предметом то
це страх не перед предметом все ж ми
розуміємо А це страх перед тим що
відбувається на уроці і тут теж є Куди
нам рухатися і думати які методики
застосовувати
І от один з моментів які я на сам кінець
перед нашою розмовою обговорював що ми
говоримо про освітні втрати ми говоримо
про те що їх Треба надолужувати звіти
хоч державної служби якості освіти хоч
наш за пілотними класами треба
опрацювати щоб подивитися над чим от в
вересні в жовтні треба попрацювати бо
друзі
до вас як пілотники звертаються коли
Минулого року в листопаді ми провели
опитування і одне питання було там таке
чи проводили ви у вересні жовтня
заходи з надолуження зокрема звертаючись
наприклад до сайту всеукраїнська школа
онлайн пілотні школи нагадує ми ж про з
вами говоримо про нас
скільки відсотків на вашу думку не
проводили жодних ніяких заходів з
надолуження або точніше ну хоча б
зходження той
Ні не так катастрофічно насправді
більше 30 від 37% наших педагогів з вами
сказали що вони у вересні-жовтні не
проводили Нічого щоб в шостому класі на
початку шостого класу е-е підтягнути
дітей в тому що буде потрібно для
шостого класу і як на мене ну мені в
тому опитуванні Якраз це був показник
найе е-е сумніший бо ми ж розуміємо що
якби ми не експериментували з нашими
дітьми нові методи не застосовували діти
перебувають у ситуації впливу
об'єктивних чинників і надолужувати
працювати на початку семестру абсолютно
з ними треба
намагаючись підтягти до того що нам
потрібно щоб теми сьомого шостого класу
а зараз сьомого класу були посильно
посилені ними і тому закликаю вас
ознайомлюючись зі звітом плануючи роботу
з надоуженням рекомендувати своїм
вчителям
все-таки в вересні жовтні от вибудувати
лінію роботи спрямовану на те щоб
підігнати те що в звіті написано як
Проблемне синтексин такси з геометричні
фігури геометричні фігури краще ви потім
надоужите програму
сьомого класу пілотті е-е трішки
утиснувши десь якісь теми поєднавши
компетентність на цій теми ніж ви зараз
пустите дітей вчити те що вони не
розуміють на жаль на початок сьомого
класу і на останок
всі пілотні школи Олена буквально тут це
важливо дуже Всі ви у своїх відгуках в
наших опитуваннях говорили що
інструменти оцінювання внизу є логотип
проєкту search який на сайті
всеукраїнської школи онлайн зараз
розміщує тести вхідні і вихідні ті які
вам уже прекрасно відомі Бо саме ці
тести ми використали для тестування а
там Зараз у нас буде і математика і
українська хімія біологія і так далі І
це вам зараз нашому вчительству Вже не
треба братись до роботи на платформі
всеукраїнської школи онлайн бо ви знаєте
як це робиться використовуйте і це вам
допоможе зрозуміти куди докладати зусиль
щоб освітні втратив пілотних школах ну
нівелювати Загалом я пишаюся що ви
продовжуєте участь в пілоті І звісно що
дані наші не покажуть багато чого але
вони підкажуть що ви можете зробити щоб
нова українська школа Ну от показала
свою силу в повні Дякую вам працюємо
далі в сьомому класі
Дякую Василя Ти звичайно не вклався але
дякую всім
продовжуючи тему моніторингу інститут
освітні аналітики
супроводжуючи Пілот з року в рік
проводили нові і нові етапи
моніторинного дослідження і
черговим етапом було дослідження
впровадження реформи нуш у пілотних
закладах освіти на рівні базової освіти
тому хочеться сьогодні почути що ж наші
школи думають про оцінювання які в них є
потреби що можна було витягнути цікавого
З цього дослідження і Я запрошую до
слова пані Валентино Ткаченко яка є
молодшим науковим співробітником на
сектору дошкільної загальної середньої
позашкільної освіти відділу статистики
аналітики інститути освітнього аналітики
пані Валентина Добрий день шановні
колеги дякую вам дуже за запрошення
І
знаєте
дуже приємно перебувати в колі
однодумців людей які команди яка
налаштовані на
спільну стратегію розвитку і Та ми із
освітнього аналітики який поспіль вже
шостий рік
просимо вас взяти участь в наших
дослідженнях щорічно і дуже вдячна
вдячні вам за те за той відгук і за ваші
відповіді І знаєте от паралельно у нас
відбувалися в інституті два дослідження
дошкільна освіта і
пілотний пілотники і
цьогоріч Міністерство ви знаєте ввели
нову таку опцію контактна особа і от я
була саме тією контактною особою які
телефонували і ви знаєте що ми не дуже
порадили там були Деякі
моменти пов'язані там технічні які
швидко ми вирішили Я сподіваюсь
Наскільки
мало було дзвінків від пілотників тому
що ми з вами вже шостий рік разом і ми
вже настільки В нас відпрацьований весь
механізм і можливо
трошки У вас таке Ой знову але так знову
і ми будемо просити вас тому що
Зрозуміло що іменістерство освіти і всім
організаторам і всім всім зацікавленим
особам на вас особисто увага і ці
дослідження вони дуже важливі для
розуміння як сказав Василь що тане Все
так вирішується легким знаєте
клацанням і оце треба вирішити було б
дуже класно Якщо ми натиснули Що Оце ви
визначите знаєте як опцію але вас чують
про це знають і намагаються зробити і
вирішити цьогоріч ми проводили саме було
зорієнтовано на те що в нас перший етап
закінчується базовий адаптативний період
тому цьогоріч ми зосередили свою увагу
на всіх учасниках пілоту і в нас були
цільова аудиторія цієї координатори
директори пілотних закладів і вчителі і
безперечно батьків уч- батьки учні
одразу хочу сказати що всі регіональні
координатори взяли участь у дослідженні
за що їм велика подяка і плюс іще е-е
координатори за освітніми галузями
директорів було дещо більше 131 але з
них семеро сказали про те що вони
припинили участь у пілоті Отже 124 особи
пілотник закладів освіти щодо батьків
хочу сказати що понад
93% які відповідали на питання вони
проживають в Україні тобто в більшості
своїй - це дані тих які навчаються Ну
деякі в більш безпечному регіоні
незначна кількість але більшість тих хто
саме е-е Ну нікуди не виїжджав або
виїжджав і повернулися
і чесно кажучи
одразу ще хочу повернутися до слайду Я
дуже дякую і Міністерство освіти команди
підтримки реформ за нашу творчу плідну
співпрацю і коли ми готували
інструментарію для цього дослідження у
нас була дискусія от цікаво ж
наскільки
оцінять Пілот самі учасники пілоту
знаєте і робили чи ставки Чи якось але
загалом загалом ви бачите що
більшість більшість все-таки більш як
поблажливі до організаторів пілоту
директори то взагалі майже 50% на оцінку
8 та такий достатній рівень
учителі трошечки розподілилися ви бачите
Да що синім це учителі помаранчевим
директорією і блакитним таким
координатори
От і але загалом ви бачите що 7-8,9 так
це найбільша
частка учасників які власне оцінили оцей
попри попри всі виклики і попри те що
Пілот півтора року
реалізується в умовах воєнного стану Але
все-таки мені здається що з цим можна
привітати з такою високою оцінкою
цього етапу пілотування ще декілька
секунд зупинюся було таке питання
оцініть Якою мірою для вас було викликом
зазначене нижче в процесі так І отут
позиції такі опції не викликало
труднощів іздебільшого не викликало
труднощів і на противагу йому
здебільшого викликало труднощів і
викликало значні труднощі Ну ви бачите
що все зелене Та ми можемо говорити тому
необхідність працювати за новими
навчальними програмами і предметами
інтегрованому курсу найбільше да
показник того що не викликало труднощів
і здебільшого не викликало труднощі
також застосовувати новий підходи це
також було не проблемним та 95,9 не
викликало іздебільшого не викликало і
нові підходи до організації роботи класу
так само бачите
93,3%. і заповнення класного журналу і
пробація апробація нових підходів до
підсумкового оцінювання це все те що
таке як тобто того що не викликало
труднощів іздебільшого не викликало
а от створювати свої навчальні матеріали
або шукати додаткові через
несвоєчасність навчально-методичного
забезпечення найвищий показник та того
що
здебільшого викликало труднощі і
викликало значні труднощі Ну я думаю що
це відповідає дійсності Ми всі з вами
про це знаємо Ну і по-новому подавати
відомості до свідоцтва досягнень за
групами результатів і розробляти
підсумкові діагностичні тести це те що
найбільше викликало і викликало значні
труднощі тому от як пас Василь сьогодні
говорив що вже є проєкт який допомагає в
цьому то я думаю що на наступний етап
нашого
пілоту і опитування Це вже буде трошечки
з цим легше
що поліпшить перебіг пілотування оце теж
дуже важливо Я вдячна за те що
ви відповідали дивіться знову таки в нас
Перше місце це що
часне забезпечення навчального
матеріалами які пілотуються зокрема
друкованими і сьогодні про це вже
звучало я повторюватися не буду та
директори директори дивіться ще крім
забезпечення чим опікується опікуються
вирішенням питання щодо належного
фінансування та це теж такий зона росту
зона росту нашого пілотного проекту Ну і
координатори
61,3 це посилення методичної підтримки з
боку організатору керівництва Так це те
що поліпшить Ну і всі інші всі інші теж
можна буде детальніше ознайомитися Ну і
підвищення кваліфікації підвищення
кваліфікації Мені дуже подобається цей
слайд якщо чесно особливо знаєте які
мотиваційні чинники хоча нам писали
вчителі що якось може це не зовсім
коректне питання і так далі але мене
особисто тішить що можливість
самореалізації для понад
60% це є знач стимулом а другий - це
взагалі супер правда тому що
якщо ми вчителі ми вчимо То ми і
навчаємося самі І от Я просто люблю свою
роботу тобто підвищувати фаховість - це
є частина нашої з вами роботи так Ну і
що ще говорить про те що нас дійсно
якась ну якась а те що відбувається
реформа Да в підвищення кваліфікації
тому що я працювала в школі я знаю так
як це все є от що можливість уникнути
санкції з боку керівництва бачите дуже
незначна
1,6%, так Тобто це не є якимось
стимулом Та все ж таки все ж таки
учителі розуміють що їм потрібно
розвиватися
щодо де
проходили впродовж останніх років курси
Ну у нас обласні інститути
післядипломної педагогічної освіти
лідирують і академії безперервної освіти
от але і
самоосвіта бачите достатньо високої
показник
понад
55%. і хочу звернути увагу що міжнародні
проєкти та 40 е-е
44% директорів відзначили що вони
навчалися завдяки в міжнародних проектах
так ну тут у нас як часто застосовуєте
знання Ви знаєте це теж було таке
питання яке мало багато опцій але не
мало значення тому що застосовують
постійно ви бачите які показники тобто
все що на курсах підвищення кваліфікації
воно допоміж неї помічне так от
[музика]
я трошки буду прискорювати бо пані Олена
та значить Дивіться це розвиток
найбільше потребують для організації
освітнього процесу в умовах может
директори це компетентність забезпечення
якості освіти та функціонування
внутрішньої системи і бачите 24 теж
функціонування зовнішньої системи так ну
і стратегічного управління і є також
інформаційна технологія теми підвищення
курсів я пропущу тому що це акт Всі ви
знаєте а от далі в останнє та
Вишенка на торті
зворотній зв'язок від батьків пілотних
класів та
не все ми тут взяли тільки деякі окремі
Я думаю те що ну на мій погляд це те що
дуже актуально дивіться чи адаптувалися
дитина до навчання після початкової
школи до навчання базової школи бачите
батьки насправді
сказали що так дитина легко адаптувалася
там майже 60%, і 32% майже 33 третина
Так
швидше Так тобто загалом загалом ми
можемо сказати що
і дитина
учителі
в більшості діти адаптувалися
домашнє завдання Та це навіть такі
мемчики ходять іриси так як діти
виконують домашні завдання але Дивіться
44% що зазначили що так вони допомагають
але з деяких предметів і майже кожен
п'ятий трохи більше що лише
Контролюю виконання так і дуже малий що
тішить що маленькі показник що виконання
домашніх завдань викликає значні
труднощі і
з усіх предметів та але це менше 10%,
якщо ви порахуєте і складете ці слайди і
останні чи задоволення Ну не останній
передачі задоволені ви освітніми
результатами дивіться дуже гарний та що
46,8% батьків сказали що є прогресне у
навчанні З певних предметом і 22 і 8
помітний прогрес у навчанні та розвитку
тобто є результати І батьки - це
оцінюють
тут би я хотіла зупинитися на останньому
Так тут про
форма свідоцтва досягнень та дивіться 40
майже 50%
нова форма свідоцтва як кажуть та зайшла
та і вона допомагає краще зрозуміти
сильні слабкі сторони і дивіться ще
16,9 А Перепрошую 22.5 що хотілося б
мати ще більше відомостей тобто батькам
ще мало в цьому свідослі досягнень
відомостей Ну і це вже останній слайд і
я дуже дякую всім за увагу Я дякую за
участь і я бажаю натхнення і
подолати всі виклики і до зустрічі в
опитуваннях наступних
дякую пані Валентино Та я вибачаюсь але
нам треба дуже прискорюватися тому що
там вже секція нагородження але в нас є
важливе ще доповідь про навчальний
матеріал про забезпечення навчальними
матеріалами про програми тому Я запрошую
до слова пані Олену Дубовик яка є
заступницею директора з
навчально-методичного забезпечення
змісту освіти інституту модернізації
змісту освіти Дякую Олена ми просто
попередні два наших доповідача говорили
про результати опитування наших пілотних
класів щодо стосується 5-6 класу цього
року пілотні заклади освіти переходять
на другий цикл базової освіти 7-9 клас
безпосередньо ми це називаємо що
предметне навчання і для того щоб
забезпечитичне навчання нам необхідні
модельні навчальні програми модель
нічого програма Ми багато чули від
представників пілотних закладів освіти
від координаторів що їх мало що вони не
вчасні що з вже із запізненнями
надається їм гриф але колії
автори створювали модельні навчальні
програми в ті часові межі наскільки їм
це вдавалося після того їх розглядали
експертні комісії і повірте мені жодна
модельне навчальна програма не змогла
одержати гриб Міністерства з першого
разу
всі модельні навчальні програми
попередні були направлені на
доопрацювання зауваження доньки до них
були
різноманітні могла бути і дуже багато і
мало але вони всі доопрацьовувалися
авторськими колективами І лише після
того були наданий гриб на сьогоднішній
день Якщо підсумувати у нас станом на
сьогодні 65 модельних навчальних програм
для 7-9 класів мають гриф міністерства
і смачного тоді по освітній галузі
мовно-літературно-освітня галузь по
предметам і інтегрованим курсом
українська мова дві модельні навчальні
програми література українська одна
зарубіжна аж три інтегрований курс
Української та зарубіжної літератури дві
інтегровані мовно-літературні курси як
ми називаємо Три в одному українська
мова українська література із зарубіжна
література одна програма мова література
керівних народів національних меншин тут
величезна цифра 21 але це якщо врахувати
то на кожну мову національної меншини
одна програма і література та може бути
інтегрований курс мови літератури
кримськотатарська мова А є окремі
наприклад Угорська і зарубіжна
література окрема угорська мова Тому так
і величезне показник іноземна мова чому
я зазначила два плюс один два цей
вивчені іноземної мови як першої
наземної і одна модельне навчальна
програма іноземна мова як друга іноземна
і хочу звернути увагу що це програми не
5Д не 7-9 а безпосередньо 5-9 на всю
базову освіту який одержали гриф ще два
роки тому що стосується наземних мов
математична освітня галузь у нас вперше
з'являється в 7-9 класах інтегроване
курс математики Раніше у нас завжди було
алгебра окремо геометрія окрема зараз
математика і одна програма вже є і ось
тут зверніть увагу перший стовпчик це
скільки програми вже надано гриф три
програми з алгебри три геометрії одна
інтегрований курс рекомендовано для
надання грифа що це означає от одна з
геометрією одна з математики комісія
дала схвальне рішення
порушила клопотання перед міністерством
освіти і науки України Про надання грифе
рекомендовано і до 1 вересня ці програми
теж будуть мати гриф і триває експертиза
ще одна програма з геометрії триває
експертиза можливо вже доопрацювання і з
часом буде наданий гриб але впевнено не
до 1 вересня це вже може бути Інна 10
вересня і трохи пізніше Це вже залежить
від того як швидко буде завершено
доопрацювання але я хочу звернути увагу
ці цифри це станом на сьогодні ніхто не
сказав щоб понеділок у вівторок чи далі
не надійдуть нові програми
як ми кажемо завжди авторами двері не
закриваємо будь-який момент програма
завершеної розробка її можна подавати і
она держать гриф за Скажімо так після
того як комісія прийме схвальне рішення
щось не хоче перемик а
природничо-освітня галузь
чотири окремих предмети які відповідають
наукам і природничі науки як
інтегрований курс всі чотири навчальних
предмети мають хоча б по одній програмі
як біологія хімії географія дрії фізика
H3 географія - це ті і модельні
навчальні програми які одержали гриф ще
рік тому що географія у нас як окреме
навчальний предмет розпочався в шостому
класі і дивіться ще є триває експертиза
ще є програми на розгляді тобто з часом
вони теж можуть одержати гриф
потенційний скажемо так варіант
природничі науки всі клітинки порожні
була подана ще навесні одна модельна
навчальна програма природничі науки але
на жаль не була схвально прийнято
рішення це інтегрований курс який
розглядає чотири комісії паралельна як
біологія географії фізики і хімії
трикомісії з чотирьох цю програму
модельну відхилили тому і нема але знов
ніхто не сказав що через деякий час
навіть до конкурсу підручників сьомого
класу така програма не буде подана Все
може бути
соціальне та здоров'я збережувальна
галузь в сьомому класі У нас лише один
навчальний предмет цієї галузі - це
здоров'я безпека та добробут продовження
з 5 класу
величезної виборчої моделі навчальні
програми
підприємство та фінансова грамотність це
з другого з 8 класу тобто другий рік
навчання в другому циклі базової школи
але програми вже є і вчителі і автори
можуть вже працювати над створенням і
навчальних матеріалів і відповідно
підручників
громадянська та історична освітня галузь
на сьогоднішній день є по одній модельні
навчальній програмі історія України
всесвітньої історії і дві інтегровані
програми
подано на до 1 вересня буде ще один
програма і історії України всесвітній і
ще триває експертиза тобто різноманіття
скажемо так тут буде
і в іншу освітньої галузі які ми
називаємо моногалузі це інформатичне
мистецька технологічна і фізкультура і
міжгалузевий курс драматургія і театр
Якщо говорити про монога галузі У нас
вони всі закриті мають всі модельні
навчальні програми і ще передано на грив
і ще триває експертиза і міжгалузевий
курс драматургії театр теж одежу
схвальне Рішення комісії і подане для
надання грифа тобто якщо підвести
підсумок то для пілотних класів які
йдуть в цьому році в 7 клас є модельні
навчальні з усіх моделі навчальні
програми з усіх навчальних предметів
інтегрованих курсів крім одного
природничі науки
на жаль так от сталося але ну Скажем так
може все ще змінитися Але станом на
сьогодні Саме так вот тому модельні
навчальні програми є наступне питаннячко
де з ними можна ознайомитися Ми і в
групі я тоді писала Олена мене просила
що всі програми яким надана гриф ми
зразу же після підписується наказ про
надання грифа розміщуємо і на сайті
Міністерства освіти і науки України і на
сайті нашого інституту в розділах
модельні навчальні програми нова
українська школа вони всі сортовані по
освітній галузях зручно їх знайти і
користуватися на них всіх зазначений
гриф яким наказом вони дати можна
працювати але у мене
наступний слайд начебто такий ну всі
знають що таке модельне навчальна
програма
чому я вивела цей слайд а тому що дуже
часто і від пілотних закладів освіти і
від тих що масово піднімається на рік
пізніше з'являється запитання чи можна
міняти модельне навчальну програму то
якщо ми освіжимо визначені що таке
модельне навчальна програма то давайте
буде свідомими якщо ми говоримо про цикл
навчання 5-6 клас чи сьомий дев'ятий
всередині цикла міняти модельну
навчальну програму не можна між циклами
Так є модельна програма на п'яте-шостий
класс є програма на 5-9 клас І якщо
після шостого класу вчитель з якихось
причин вирішив змінити будь ласка ніяких
заперечень а от всередині ні чому Тому
що розгортання очі досягнення очікуваних
результатів кожні модельній програмі
своє навіть теми які схожі можуть бути
Наприклад якщо ми говоримо проявляти 6
клас в одному авторському колективі в
програмі в першому класі а у іншого - це
шостий клас і тоді це буде
невідповідність якщо бути вчитель
підлаштовувати створювати якусь
навчальну програму так щоб перейти на
іншу модельну це не буде навчальна
програма розроблена відповідно до
модельної навчальної це зовсім інше
навчальна програма тому таке робити не
можна до чого я це веду зараз пілотні
заклади освіти будуть обирати модельні
навчальні програми за якими вони будуть
працювати де одна питань нема вона та на
1 вересня А де кілька дуже важлива
свідомо підійти до вибору так щоб потім
не було ситуації що ви вибрали ту
програму яка
трошки не ваша не підходить під ваш
стиль Роботи під той учнівський колектив
з який ви працюєте дуже-дуже свідомо і
останнє навчальні матеріали під ці
модельні навчальні програми знов ми
проаналізували перепитали всі
видавництва авторські колективи під всі
модельні навчальні програми на
сьогоднішній день створюється або вже
створені навчальні матеріали частина вже
подана нам на розгляд для грипування Ми
дуже Скажем так уважно радилися з
колегами як правильно зробити сьогодні
25 серпня ми всі свідомі того що до
початку навчального року вже Менше тижня
ну тиждень бажаємо так
встигнути і розглянути і надати гриф не
всім навчальним матеріалам буде просто
фізична можливість тому Ми домовились
таким чином що ми перші частини
навчальних матеріалів будемо розглядати
з метою надання грифа і передаватись
вони будуть в заклади пілотні паралельно
щоб не втратити оцей час щоби і Вчителі
були Скажем так
скажемо надані їм навчальні матеріали і
можна було якщо будуть знайдено якісь
недоречності це буде в електронному
вигляді Можна було б відправити І
передати в закладах освіти оновлену
версію сьогодні говорили багато про
паперові примірники вона перше панельний
дискусії заступник Міністра Андрій
Сташків сказав що буде підписана
постанова кабміна коли про
фінансування за рахунок субвенції і тоді
теж буде можливість поговорити про
паперовий примірники тобто все рухається
в тому щоб пілотні заклади освіти були
повністю забезпечені і модельними
навчальними програмами і навчальними
матеріалами розробленими до них
дякуємо за увагу
детально роз'яснення щодо навчальних
навчально-методичних забезпечення
пілотів колеги з друзів останнє але не
менш важливе питання Сьогодні я
сподіваюсь що це буде дуже коротко У нас
сьогодні заступник Міністра згадував про
те що Пілот профільної старшої школи
розпочнеться у 2025 році важливо
зрозуміти що має відбутися для
реалізації пілоту і яка може бути у
цьому підтримка від комітету Верховної
Ради з питання освіти науки та інновацій
тому у нас сьогодні є наша колега це
секретарка цього комітету Наталія піпа
вона нас під'єднана онлайн дякую Наталя
що дочекалися ми трошки збилися з
графіку Я надаю вам слово Для того щоб
ви представили те як комітет може
підтримувати процес впровадження пілоту
доброго
е-е кажуть що нардепи говорить довго я
буду максимально коротко знаю як і по
суті щодо пілоту профільної школи І що
може зробити комітет е-е основна як на
мене І це те що відстояли від початку те
що внесли зміни в законодавство про
можливість двох класів
трьох класів на паралелі і два
напрямки два профілі Я вважаю далі що це
є неправильним як на мене максимум
будемо говорити комітети що повернути
стару норму від 50 000 про містах І
точно що нам треба змінювати це вже
більше залежить від Міністерства від
положення адже якщо піти тим шляхом щоб
пропонується сьогодні це означає що
маленька громада бере школу в якій буде
три класи по 5 дітей пробуємо профіль
математичний Роберт профіль в
гуманітарний чуть-чуть трошки зміню
програми і Нічого по суті не змінюється
і От коли ми 2025 будемо сподівати
запускати Пілот А на сьогодні це
планується 20 в кожній області по одному
гумані ліцею академічному і по два
професійних ліцей чи коледжі не коледжі
технікуми чи про техніки як це буде
називатися Нам треба зробити і Показати
цю модель тому
комітет буде далі над цим працювати
комунікати Бо це не була наша ініціатива
змінювати цей закон і наполягатиме те
щоби ці зміни внеслися а Відповідно ми
розробили модель бо Пілот чим буде І
взагалі чим буде профільна школа складна
що окрім того що зміни програм нам треба
ще більше навчити вчителів Звичайно що і
шукати Із підвищенням заробітної плати
але також нам потрібно зміна мережі і
тут ми отримуємо найбільший опір і тут
найбіль ше Нам потрібні зміни тому я
дуже дякую за цю аналітику що я сьогодні
почула нам точно ми не маємо права
зупинятися і
виклики будуть дуже багато те як в нас
мало часу не буду зосереджуватись на
решта деталей дякую
дякую дякую
дуже
колеги слухачі ті хто бачать нас онлайн
трансляція ми вже дуже вибилася з часу
тому на цьому насправді наша Панельна
дискусія буде завершена ще раз хочеться
підкреслити що сьогодні ми почули про
титанічну величезну роботу щоденну яку
впроваджують прості люди але вони не
прості Вони люди з великим серцем з
Надією з вірою в реформу вірив дітей і
Вірою в цілі які ми маємо впроваджувати
в реформі нової української школи і ще
раз низький уклін за ваші історією
особлива емоційні особливо складні те що
ви поділилися ми всі почули наскільки
складно зараз в умовах війни
впроваджувати Пілот але ці люди вони не
здаються вони не складають руки і це не
тільки пілотни школи і кожен і кожна Хто
там працює але це теж потужна команда
установ задіяних в тому щоб Пілот
реалізувався і команди авторів і
видавництв і всі абсолютно інституції
які залу до того щоб Пілот був успішним
ми більш ніж впевнені що так і буде У
нас є потужна команда гравців у нас є
потужна команда реалізатори реформи і ми
це робимо заради наших дітей ми сьогодні
бачили багато красивих хороших
надихаючих світлин дітей і ми чули
просто статистику опитувань про те як
вони хочуть бачити себе вільній Україні
хочуть продовжувати отримувати якісну
освіту і це найголовніше тому я вірю що
ми з вами зустрінемось наступного разу
ще раз підкреслюю вільний Україні
завдяки нашим збройним силам України
який будуть крок за кроком це робити як
ми з вами тут в нашому освітньому фронті
робимо зміни Так вони будуть допомагати
нам втілювати в мирні часи мирній
Україні тому я дякую ще раз всім
учасникам Дякую всім нашим глядачам які
мали терпіння незважаючи на те що ми
виявилися з часом вона терпіння до
слухати про ці всі грандіозні результати
які ми маємо тому бажаємо всім Гарного
дня спокійного і щоб скоріше настала
перемога яку ми всі хочемо Слава Україні
Героям слава